that's what a professional does
professional turns that [ __ ] down on
down huh a non-professional or someone
who's half-assing it they keep that
phone up really yeah have you seen that
yeah some people keep that phone up
checked that phone on time they'll check
in the middle podcast Russell Peter
can't leave his phone alone really try
getting through a [ __ ] whole podcast
with Russell Peters without I'm checking
his tweets what's impossible impossible
he's checking things sometimes you read
off tweets and say oh people Oh Doug
Benson used to do that that's why I read
off the tweets I'm trying to get away
from it if I can I'll find times if I'm
gonna go eat now I'll even leave it at
my phone in the car yes Power Move and I
hadn't done that before I just started
and it's not even a natural choice I'm
making almost it's like something I need
to do yeah it's a [ __ ] move all
right you're scared scared to leave it
in there
yeah scared scared to leave that phone
would have something important I guess I
needed to know but there isn't there is
a thing like what if something important
happens yeah but what is you think like
when does that happen
super rare but if it did happen why your
phone was in the car and somebody needed
you you'd feel terrible right but you
gotta just what is the what's the
balance it's like it's so slippery we
didn't have any way to get in touch with
back in the day you had to yell for help
number that yeah you can't yell huh yeah
not in Los Angeles there's too many
people you yell for help nobody's in
some languages helped me in something
else I think it's you know something not
good or something Arabic or something
people will [ __ ] you up just make that
up I'm not sure honestly I think I might
have heard that because I live in
Westwood and we have it's very diverse
over there's a lot of people sometimes
yell and stuff in the street do you
think for real do you think help mean
something bad in other languages is that
real
somebody told me hello means go to hell
in like Greek or Latin like um like
politics means like political like up
like um something like not good like
something tick like a tick like
blood-sucking oh really
government or something like that let's
start
with one let's start with should we do
with hello first yeah I think cuz and I
just say things and I don't even know
sometimes think if somebody just told me
to say hello when I was young and I've
been saying in my whole life but what
does help mean is help mean anything in
another language is help a bad word in
other languages okay I'm looking up if
the word help means something in another
language not right there word help you
got if the word help mean something in
another language that I think you mean
you're gonna have to rewarded it you're
gonna have to word it uniquely I think
cuz it's a that's a hard one that's a
that's a that's yeah I don't even know
anymore now be its translation that
might may be an Arabic or something like
that have any sort of alternate meanings
and other languages
yeah I'm not accusing anybody the Arab
nations or whatever Asians or whatever
you know Arabic and Hebrew like those
old old languages have the coolest
letters yeah way they write things like
you look at some old Hindu script or
something like that why is that looks so
cool it seemed like a mystery yeah man
anytime like even Russian when you see
Russian written out you're like whoa
look at the crazy little letters they
have like look at that like this is like
some alien writing yeah I'd be furious
I'm Dalek I couldn't I couldn't imagine
having to learn some of the other
languages you know like I'm going to
China next week when we want to Shanghai
and I'm like it's basically just me
looking around at different drawings you
know like as far as even though words go
it's gonna be I think they have a lot of
stuff in English there oh yeah yeah are
there a lot of a lot of countries where
there's a lot of tourism they just put
stuff in English English seems to be a
language that most European countries
like most people know you could you can
kind of get by in Italy you can kind of
get by in Germany they just speak
English it's uh it's it's real
interesting man because it's because I
guess there's so much tourism and I
guess what everyone's worried about us
because we have the nuclear bombs
everybody learned English and we
traveled a lot because we have more
money here probably so we have the
ability to go places maybe hmm
do you like English that's the only
language I know yeah yeah I like it
but it's just weird how much cooler
other languages look when they're
written out I guess it's just because
what we're accustomed to like Thai you
look at Thai writing or like yeah I was
sweating I tried to read some one time
and Thai I was sweating by the end of it
how crazy is that
that's crazy food yeah like it's just
like it took me out of my element man
there's a couple of uh a couple of words
off I you know I almost needed help
Asian characters look like if you had a
movie like a science fiction movie and
in the movie they found a crashed UFO
and I had some writing on the i-beams or
something like that hmm
would look like a lot of Asian writing
right it would look like something
something crazy from Asia that like you
like what am I looking at right like a
lease you saying it might as well be
alien writing if you don't know it yeah
if there were alien writing you think
it's gonna look more like something from
Asian writing than it is from American
writing well be weird if it was like
comic book font yeah like that or
whatever it's like wait a minute
aliens speak English yeah bro everybody
does what if aliens were like a Boeing
Shuttle man that's the biggest mind [ __ ]
that I ever heard was that because the
size of infinity mm-hmm not only is
there another Theo von out there in the
world but there because infinity is so
big I'm gonna butcher this for sure yeah
we talked about this a little bit last
one was in I did we the only thing
you've ever done
someone has done the exact same things
in the exact same order down to the last
millisecond do you believe do you okay
so that's something that you'd think or
that's something you think that could be
really true I think it could be really
true but honestly my brain is not really
strong enough to compute that so I would
have to take many many many hours really
thinking about what that means because
right now when I'm saying even when I'm
saying them I it's one of those whoa
dude things like I'm saying it but I'm
not really thinking it through yeah like
how much how how much you really
thinking through yeah just a couple
steps you don't really think
okay that there's a so then that means
for you there's another there's another
man out there who did comedy at last
hand at the Comedy Store who wore did
the exact same set tripped over the
exact same words spilt his water the
same way every it's supposed to be
everything and not not only that because
infinity so big they're supposed to be
an infinite number of those people out
there yeah I don't want that I don't man
cuz that would hurt my feelings honestly
it would make me feel I think it wakes
heads I think it makes sense I think the
universe is so big right I mean
everything's so big just what we know
about our solar system so big it's so
big that alone is crazy the idea that
there's no end of the crazy we're like
no no it's got to be an end no no no no
but no no that's too crazy yeah like
what's too crazy when it comes to the
universe the universe is crazy there's
nothing about it that makes any [ __ ]
sense
I mean it's so crazy that we don't like
to think about it last night I was
watching the fireworks and the fireworks
were going off and I was thinking yeah
this is kind of cool you know what's
cooler the [ __ ] billions of flying
explosions that are above our heads yeah
the free fireworks that are constantly
in the sky it's like we just will get
together for like some something made in
Honduras each other but the fact that
they're like shooting stars every night
yeah and we like because of street
lights we don't see the craziest light
show ever which is the Milky Way yeah
you know when you drive make that drive
like out to Vegas or you know into you
drive it through Montana at night or
something like that you pull over mm-hmm
what is that is that fireworks from last
night Wow that's last night is from the
NBC for helicopter that's crazy
Pasadena to downtown that's awesome
those are illegal
at least half of them are illegal right
I would say most of them are illegal it
looks like a lot of like kind of Civil
War artwork it's also sped up dude for a
firefighter that has got to be a crazy
time but some of them get off I think on
fires like some of my think they want a
little bit of fire you don't think yes
well it's been proven that some people
that are mentally ill that become
firemen
we start fires something you know it's
not it's not 99.999% of them or one of
the numbers but occasionally in every
line of work you get someone who's crazy
yeah and I could see that dude you want
something going and you don't have a lot
of money or anything like that it's also
just that one of their crazy yeah you
know they're just some people there's
something wrong right there's there's
connections that aren't being made in
there and they're not they they're
capable of doing things just to deceive
people rip people off or they're capable
of doing things for their own personal
gain like lighting a building on fire
just so they could put it out right
there's some people that are just broken
like there's something about them that's
just not connected right yeah we should
shut them down man I think I think in
the future we have to have some better
programs to find out who's just not even
care about people yeah yeah there's
people that yeah that's a really good
pair about people who doesn't care about
people because if you don't care about
people then it's just not then you
shouldn't be here you should be
somewhere else you should be in a place
where they don't have any people you
know yeah it's just a dangerous thing to
have around for the most part it's fine
right because life is fairly easy in
civilized times right most of stuff is
fine most of this stuff yeah without you
know the caveat for the occasional chaos
but it's just [ __ ] it's hard to tell
how crazy people are until something
really happens and I mean you really
need to count on them and when they you
know and you're pinned underneath a
dresser and they look at you and they
just run out of the room and just take
off and like you're not even gonna help
me there's people like that do you think
some of those people didn't even know
there that they would do that until the
situation arises then that sometimes
well I would love to have some and I
know this sounds a little dark but like
to have some serious stressors in our
world to find out even who I really am
you know like to see who rises to like
who you are inside yeah right like what
rises to the core of my skin and says
this is who I am you know like I got
trapped in an elevator once do with like
seven or eight people okay and this
sounds like a small idea but this was
like three hours right and suddenly like
a first one dudes kind of verbose he's
suddenly like I'm the leader but like an
hour later he's like trying to [ __ ] a
couple chicks that are also
in the elevator and you start to see
like okay he was trying to [ __ ] them
like it was hitting on them or he's
trying to actually get down in the
elevator no he wasn't kind of [ __ ]
over he was maybe gonna [ __ ] him later
if they got out of the elevator safely
not like a raper like a guy who's like
gonna date him or like take him to
dinner and then hopefully have sex with
him at some point if they want to as
well but he being on saying yeah
consensual sex yeah yeah there you go
but he but you started to see who was
who like one guy was like just literally
wouldn't listen anyone tried to rip the
doors open for two hours hit like just
like just like gave up on that like one
lady was really scared like immediately
it started to kind of fold out who was
gonna be who you know I wouldn't know
what to do I don't know if you're see I
don't think you're supposed to climb out
though that seems like death
right like to climb out into that shaft
you're supposed to stay yeah I know
you're supposed to yeah I mean they must
have some sort of regular but you know
of an elevator fell in one of the UFC
hotels like real far and [ __ ] up CB
Dollaway
one of the UFC fighters his back is
[ __ ] up from that apparently
apparently he's suing and I don't think
he fought that day I think they had to
cancel his fight I think I might be
wrong about that but I know his back was
like significantly [ __ ] up from that
fall elevators make it too easy man I
miss the old day sometimes when you just
he scratched from the fight yeah and
he's fought since but I think he's still
having problems with his back yeah yeah
it's hard to fix to a back it's one of
the hardest one of the hardest things to
make better again it seems like every
time people get surgery it's just a
slippery slope it's very rare that
someone gets surgery on their back and
they go oh my back's great now
everything's fine it's always like yeah
I got to go in again I got another disc
like oh no and state they're literally
getting their back fused from top to
bottom and they're back that are still
fighters too
yup no way Tito has several fused in his
neck he has artificial spacers from
where the discs used to be yeah he has
in his back his multiple operations on
his back do you think that that like
because some people think like you know
a lot of your Chi and you're like line
up is you know like your do you think
that that could alter knee of it yeah I
don't know I don't know if that's real I
don't know what is that is it is it the
actual disc gelatin or is the the spine
itself the spinal column where all the
all the nerves are firing all the way up
to the brainstem
yeah this really [ __ ] crazy thing to
risk if you think that about that like
the connection between your brain and
then that cord that goes to all your
body and everything moving and it's all
just this back area that very few people
ever even exercise yeah which is so
crazy
everybody's doing all this [ __ ] to get
your biceps look and fly and pump your
tits up and very few people are
concentrating on like lower back
exercises reversing Pipers protecting
your spine putting muscle all around
that [ __ ]
work that core do like kettlebell
windmills you ever do kettlebell
windmills no I do do that [ __ ] they're
so good
kettlebell windmills you like you press
the kettle button you go down and touch
your touch the ground by your foot and
then straighten Wow for your spine like
all the muscles around your back that
stabilize everything and your obliques
and your abs and all your core yeah it's
a great exercise I got to do more like
adult fitness man I got a G that's what
it looks like damn look at all that [ __ ]
that's a human spine Oh like I'm gonna
eat this in China next week anyway you
can have dick over there somebody said
they can you gonna have human a human
and dick Carroll what do you month said
that and he's eaten a lot of all he's
eaten every where is he Andrew Zimmerman
honored food guy yeah the podcast yeah
he's a chef travels all over the world
really cool guy
welcome this is that pictures [ __ ]
bizarre man to think that that's all the
stuff that's firing your nerves that's
crazy and what is that what does it even
look like it almost looks like a
jellyfish or like a it looks like it's
reaching for something doesn't it
yeah it's shooting off into the cosmos
son
thing at the top is making nuclear bombs
at the top is making 4G cellphones and
40 megapixel front-facing cameras I
think it's making that thing is making
time machines yeah that [ __ ] thing is
making satellite transmission of video
signals and simultaneously delivered to
televisions worldwide that's what that
thing's making dude you got things
making Tesla's Rory's making pistols and
steroids that thing's making oxycontin
that [ __ ] thing's making everything
that's what's tough about the human
brain areas that we yeah things making
whiskey that thing's making crystal meth
and crank things making nail-polish and
fake tits that thing is off the job if
you look at if you look to the human
brain for like all this [ __ ] is
responsible for you like what that area
oh my god and it looks like something
you would think maybe wouldn't even do
nothing if you walk by that on the
street you didn't know as a brain you'd
be like ah man that's one of the my
favorite out here
is Mars Attacks where they have their
exposed brain I can't remember that you
don't remember Mars Attacks I never seen
anything never saw Mars Attacks
from watch although this is one of the
greatest movies of all time it's Tim
Burton right is that who I believe is
why it's amazing it's so good dude
Jack Nicholson is in it and he please
place two obviously different people oh
really but it's obviously the same guy
playing two people and it's never
brought up no it's a great movie man I
mean it is a great great movie it looks
bad dude it's so good it's really it
seems like it looks back if you're
watching here but it's all on purpose
yeah it's all on purpose it's like when
the when this it's what it is is they
somehow or another captured how we feel
about this time period they captured it
with this weird like Vegas thing with
this is the president back then and when
these aliens come off this spaceship
it's there something about the way they
move that makes you think like you're
watching a movie from the 50
but still really good like just good
enough but what he did by making the
effects weird and barely real as he
almost gave you a nostalgia for like
1960s 1970s movie I can see that a
little bit right here yeah but but it's
better right it's way better than
anything they were capable of I mean
look at the [ __ ] the shadows on the
head and everything like that watch a
little bit of this real quick this is
when they first land
yeah
[Applause]
they came in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
on Mars
[Music]
that's cool do you think you'd eat
something from Mars if they had like if
they had it say this because I know
you'd like to be a wild eater I've seen
some of the stuff you eat you know you'd
be kind of rare you know you you know
you know you're not afraid to eat the
rare and would you have say this they
catch a Mars donkey or something you
know and they're just they're serving
enough you don't even know what's in it
bro alright the ultimate Eyes Wide Shut
party serving up a donkey from Mars
how many pounds of that thing I would
need it
no chance first of all people first of
all people gonna be definitely mad at
you you think people are mad at you for
eating animals on earth yeah imagine
eating animals from space only one it
would be so [ __ ] mad at you
second of all I would want I would not
want to be an early adopter of Mars meat
really I want to sit back look these
people that are convinced that meat I
don't agree with them but there's people
that are convinced that meat is bad for
you that meat itself is bad for you yeah
because a lot of people that eat meat
wind up with a bunch of heart disease
the problem is that they're not really
measuring just the meat they're just
measuring people that eat meat what else
do you eat oh you eat a lot of sugar you
have a lot of bread you have a lot of
pasta you eat a lot of this and a lot
you drink oh nice yeah you might have
you might smoke cigarettes yeah so it's
hard to tell and I think different
things are also different for different
people but people can't even agree on
whether or not it's healthy to eat meat
there's some people that disagree on it
right but wouldn't you want to wait to
see what Mars me but wouldn't you want a
[ __ ] wild one oh sit back have you
like dude I'm good with bison you can
eat those Mars donkeys all day long I'm
gonna see what a 20 year profile of
[ __ ] donkeys from Mars eaters looks
like Levin Stardust steak or something
out of Mars they only have one bounce in
that one donkey yeah but it could be so
like some prions getting your system you
got mad cow disease likewise you could
also what if you adopt a superpower by
eating it
that's good true that's one thing that
nobody ever brings up with like nuclear
energy like all this all these like
nuclear disasters everybody's terrified
of mutations and radioactive waves and
all the [ __ ] that's gonna [ __ ] us up
nobody remembers comic books where every
single time somebody got hit with some
radioactive [ __ ] they became a superhero
to be around that's never happened here
I wonder if I could handle the dude if I
had a superpower I just feel like I
would tell everyone I wouldn't be able
to keep it a secret
hmm some secret powers you're allowed to
just tell everybody some dudes they just
tell everybody right like who doesn't
have to keep it a secret
obviously the thing he can't keep it a
secret
what is that at the big x-men they're
like had to go yeah but they had high
but the thing doesn't hide the thing is
just that's what he's covered in rocks
you know oh yeah oh yeah I know yeah but
the fists yeah giant clobber time
who else um doesn't have to hide
anything you can't hide anything
bruising Bannister who was banner
Bruce Banner Bruce Banner do you know
when they sure as a carpenter no no do
you know that when they did the
incredible health TV show they changed
his name from Bruce to David because
people thought Bruce was gay uh really
yep was a lot of Bruce's gay then dude
that's always been the stereotypical
name oh wait what kind of comedian would
do a hack joke about a gay guy they'd be
like Bruce yeah Randy Randy Oh Randy
really I would never heard Randy but
Bruce it's always been Bruce is the name
that they would use so apparently people
in then you know what it was the 70s
when the Hulk TV show was around with
Lou Ferrigno oh yeah yeah they just
decided like hey let's let's change this
name change it make it David David
Banner and we also comic-book dorks like
me were like what how dare you how dare
you change his name that was the best
show ever because it made it feel like
me if you were ugly you could still be
cool and do neat stuff I felt like well
it was the Revenge of people who were
bullied and picked on there's the idea
that you you could be this nerdy guy and
you get picked on by these [ __ ] and
you just [ __ ] Hulk out and become
bulletproof yeah I met him at the post
office one time no Ferrigno I met him
he's a real nice guy
yeah he seemed nice he was with a lady
friend and it might have been his wife I
think he's still yoked his [ __ ] he's
jacked like you know um he looked
really good like he looks healthy too
it's crazy yeah I mean the dude's got to
be deep into his 60s but he looks very
healthy he might I wonder who I wonder
if you were gonna start living for like
a really long look at him there that
dude looks healthy as [ __ ] now he dare
he looks a little bit more more
reasonable yeah I mean look he was a
gigantic super-sized human at one point
in time you know money that's what he
used to look like so big so when you saw
him on the Hulk the problem was he
couldn't really be that defined for long
periods of time and film a television
show because it was too unhealthy oh
it's super unhealthy when those guys are
like right about to pose down when
they're about to they're on death's door
they're really unhealthy they get light
head look at that dude oldest [ __ ] who's
sad old and jacked yeah Willie Nelson
looks like a 75 year old jack man see
they have those you eat that bro say
that guy gets shot and killed it
depends how far I am from civilization
okay let's say you're far man yeah I
need them yeah I need him if it was but
whether or not eating him or not
surviving getting home to my family or
something like that okay say this thing
I'm gonna put you under a little bit of
um some if you don't mind is that okay
okay so a ship went down a shuttle an
airship or something a plane and you
know like that movie alive right you're
out there do you are you the chef you
know you're gonna eat it you know you're
gonna eat well it's whether or not the
bodies like the people are killed
already the real problem is that people
start killing people and eating people
then you got a real problem okay people
are already killed people are already
dead it's to senior citizens that's it
it was a small plane well you got to
decide people can live without food for
several weeks especially if you're the
average American you got a lot of fat in
your body after a day or so your body
kicks into fat-burning ketosis mode but
you're gonna be hungry yeah you're gonna
be hungry but you will be less hungry
believe it or not after the first day
once your body kicks into fat burning
like have you ever been on a fat burning
diet I've just on paleo for a month
little different paleo you're still
eating a lot of carbohydrates just
cutting out all the grains and things
like that yeah
when you go on a fat burning diet one of
the first things that happens is your
appetite just changes radically it's
really weird like you just stop being
hungry the same way like hunger isn't a
desperation thing like when I know when
I'm not ketogenic because then my hunger
gets desperate like I have to eat
something like I feel like ooh I never
feel like that with keto it's like I'm
hungry but I'm okay
right it's like and through the day like
energy levels are much more stabilized
that's what I felt like on paleo I've
never done anything like that I mean I
lost like 11 pounds with someone think I
was supposed to lose like I don't really
have like a plan or anything but next
thing you know like I felt I never felt
like I had to eat I felt like I needed
to eat to get to the next few moments of
my life but I didn't feel like okay I
got to make a big deal about eating it
felt more like a survival technique mmm
like eating all day and then my mind I
felt I did he feel more energy I never
felt like that after eating I always
felt like okay I could eat and then
still go do something I could go you
know play cards or run around or you
know chase a friend or do anything you
know hang out yeah um so who's you know
you would have to you don't have to
first of all talk to everybody about
know cuz you got like I said you got two
weeks right you got two weeks for your
body could just go on fat eating itself
started the your body starts eating
itself
okay you got to talk to people and say
listen this person is dead okay this is
just meat now that can keep us alive and
we can survive and we could see our
family and our friends or we cannot eat
this person and would take a chance on
going hungry and we might get too weak
to get out of here like you have to
think like what if what if you can get
saved but you have to be able to hike
out 30 miles in the mountain okay so
you're really planning ahead then a lot
of you have to you have to you you're
you're either gonna die or you're gonna
live okay these are the only two things
that could possibly happen that in that
even matter that point so you got to
figure out is it even possible that you
can live
is it possible yeah you might be might
not be you might be in the mountains in
the winter with nothing around you to
eat no way for you to get off the
mountain because it's too dangerous
because you get cliffed out every time
you try to go down and then you try to
get back up and you can't get back up
and you're stuck you could fall and die
it happens to people all the time so
it's it might not be that you can make
it but if you are gonna make it out
you're gonna want to have some energy
and different people have different
fitness levels obviously so some people
like they're not even gonna be capable
of hiking out what if you take a lunch I
mean you don't have to eat the whole
person right then like you guys could
yeah you would eat them in parts for
sure what would you have it's a
psychologically devastating the thought
of just eating human meat it's
psychologically devastating you you're
crossing a threshold that you know
you're in you're in - it's a dark arts I
mean it's everything is everything it's
sad it's it's crazy and it's also a rich
part of you know human adventure history
there was always like you run into
cannibals you know it was like a big
part of those crazy movies about oh yeah
is it in the jungle they got eaten by
cannibals even Brady Bunch remember they
came across some people I think they
were cannibals or they went in like ever
cross cannibal haha but like all even
cartoons all of them did it was
cannibals or like da Joe versus the
volcano remember that and I don't
remember that I think he came across
cannibals well there was an Hannibal's
in history a lot of cannibals I didn't
know that there was so much cannibalism
amongst Native Americans like Native
Americans would cannibalize settlers
some of them like the Nez Perce Indians
Steve Rinella was telling me about that
they would cut dudes up and eat them
like whoa that's that's crazy imagine
yeah if somebody goes down and ulis and
there's a part you already know you like
you're like oh I'm cutting this dude
understand I'm having a little bit of
[ __ ] ligament right here on this
hillside man a guy killed by a polar
bear yesterday in front of his kids in
Canada he was protecting his kids from
the polar bear and he died 31 year old
dude you know what that's a hero though
I mean these kids will think of him as a
hero I bet he lives in that same place
where those people live on that life
below zero
I think it's called Nunavut if people
know that's where he lives he lives I
mean he lives
in a really really remote area that has
polar bears mmm polar bears have the
most dangerous bear you could ever run
into because they're the only animal
that all of them actively hunt people
really Nunavut that's the place where it
was
yeah they hunt everything everything
that moves they all don't have any
vegetables up there so they don't
they're the only a hundred percent
carnivorous bear all they eat is me all
the eight is meet every other bear is
like eating berries and bears no ignore
you if they forget a whole field for a
berries well I don't want to chase you
[ __ ] and chew your bones and all that
[ __ ]
I'm just gonna eat berries what are the
lazy bears there's some very laid on his
back
they love berries much you find like
giant fields of blueberries you'll find
bears just snacking away having a great
time eating blueberries they'll do it
all day not polar bears polar bears eat
your [ __ ]
kill you they kill everything man oh I
would hate that dude I would hey if
someone's trying to eat me man I would
just be so upset I think yeah did you
see that lady that got in trouble cuz
she shot a giraffe
she shot I did see yeah she shot a rare
giraffe and so everybody's freaking out
on her it seems sad man that giraffe
seemed like it probably what was he
gonna do to her it's not gonna do
anything to her for sure it's it is rare
for an animal to get that old it's 18
years old it's real dark yeah it had
dark skin or something a little yeah the
old males they get dark this is super
cool one thing though that people need
to know see all these things are
complicated they're not as simple as
everybody wants to think they are and
this is one of the things that's
complicated about this store is that
that giraffe is killing little giraffes
it's a normal thing the old bulls like
that one which is a big massive 18 year
old animal okay it's a huge huge animal
he just was not having it with these
young ones coming up not having it what
do you think it is jealousy or anger
it's just nature
you know they kill off the younger males
oh yeah like pissed at the neighbor kids
kind of thing don't they just don't want
anybody taking their spot they don't
know that they're riding off from the
sunset like he's not a viable breeding
male anymore
huge so at 18 years of age he had killed
off three young bulls so they were gonna
have to kill him right because it's not
good you need the Bulls to keep the
thing alive what was well not just that
he this is a species of giraffe that
already has a population problem there's
not a lot of them and if he's killing
off these young Bulls each one of those
young bulls could have fathered
countless children yeah so they're
missing all these future children for
one bull who can't even breathe anymore
and he's gonna continue to do it he was
seeking out the young bulls he already
killed three like this is not a cut and
dry thing I don't think it looks cool to
pose with a rifle and a giraffe and I
mean there's something about giraffes
that are so gentle that they let kids
feed them when you go to the [ __ ] zoo
right I don't so I get why people would
be upset but when you find out what it
actually is you go oh this is not it's
this is more complicated than I'm that
I'm seeing on the surface it's not
simply a cruel person shot at giraffe
and we should be angry too right it's
like no they had to shoot that giraffe
because it was killing other giraffes
so is it appropriate the way she
celebrated it that's when you have to
wonder yeah but they were eating it I
mean that's the other thing it's like
they got [ __ ] eight hundred pounds of
meat or something like that out of that
Wow
it's a huge animal I think it was more
than that didn't they say 2,000 pounds
of meat I think it's a 4000 pound animal
and they got 2,000 pounds of meat which
they give to all the villages all the
people there and I know people are like
wait I don't give a [ __ ] you shouldn't
shoot a giraffe
I feel the same way because when I see a
giraffe I don't think of it as something
I want to shoot and eat yeah I think of
it as something a little kid can feed at
the [ __ ] zoo because they're so
gentle they're so gentle that they like
people feed them oh yeah they had a
thing by our home when I was growing up
they had a thing do that a couple
giraffes out there a couple of lambs and
[ __ ] yeah get out there and buy a little
cup of corn and go out there and you
don't even have to know it like you know
it's a sign a wave you have to do
anything you even have to [ __ ] be
able to read very well and you can
[ __ ] feed a giraffe you know
point-blank it's the only animal that is
a wild African animal that we let kids
feed yeah at the [ __ ] zoo little kids
can feed them yeah
I can't believe that that is that much I
mean when I hear that for one the lady
would did she why did she have to put
that picture out what was in it for her
to do that she even knew like she's a
hunter and she was excited that she got
to kill a big giraffe you know and the
you know it gets it's it gets strange
when you just tail a bunch of things and
make stuff trophies and you put them in
your trophy room and you go well I want
to get it now I want to get a ram okay I
got a ram now I want to get a mountain
goat okay and you got like this
menagerie inside of your yeah that's it
gets dark man now I want to get a mouse
now I want to get a stepdad now I want
to get a second but then I it's like
okay but if you're eating all of those
things and this is how you get your meat
yeah is that okay
well yeah it's okay but there's
something we did something we all have a
strange feeling about this the idea is
that people are killing these things and
they're getting some kind of pleasure
out of it and they're not doing it just
to eat it right it's so like even if you
you are gonna eat it we don't want you
to be really happy when you kill
something that's it - that's some of it
I think the villagers should have be
able the ones that should vote on if it
was okay or not it's in their village
they would vote okay every time because
they get money from it then to me then
that seems okay because a lot of times
it's like we're judging things from so
far away we won't even know we even know
what it's like we're talking about
completely different dynamics in terms
of like the way their culture works
first of all the money for these big
hunts that these people pay to shoot all
these different things down there that's
a shitload of money and that shitload of
money for that area for that part of the
world is gigantic fuels conservation
efforts it pays for these people that
are essentially their version of game
wardens you know and then they have
these different people that are employed
by these hunting companies and then
there's resources to stop poaching and
then resources to actively participate
in controlling habitat and making sure
these animals are in healthy populations
and bringing their numbers up this is
all done through the money that comes
from hunting so soup it's super [ __ ]
up right it's it's weird because it
doesn't make sense it's like the people
that are paying
to keep these animal lives or also the
ones that want to shoot up people what
the it's we would like it to be all the
conservation money comes from people who
just love animals and want to keep them
alive but that's not the case that's not
the case no the money comes almost I
mean it's not exclusively because there
are a lot of conservation groups that do
donate for wildlife protection and for
preserving of animal habitats there are
there's there's definitely some people
that donate right but there's no it's
not even close to the amount of money
that's raised from hunting tag and
especially hunting you're on that local
level like you're you know like some of
these like these programs I'm sure there
are a little bit more bigger more
blanket you know but you get into that
local level fifty thousand dollars can
keep you know a small town or a small
habitat around for the year ya know
who's getting all that money but you're
right it's but it makes us uncomfortable
but rightly so I mean you're looking at
a giraffe you want giraffes to stay
alive you say like that's amazing but we
have to know that the facts behind it in
this particular case were they that
giraffe had to go yeah that giraffe was
killing giraffes you ever see him fight
it's the most oh yeah thing they just
headbutt each other they swing their
head like a like a mace smash into each
other it's what a terrible way to fight
it's [ __ ] crazy just suck at fighting
oesophagus yeah [ __ ] yeah it's like
crystal it's almost like Chris D'Elia
maybe were in a fight you loved his
esophagus I love Chris D'Elia very
prominent target if you wanted to hit
something have you seen how he had this
funny thing of this Jaguar challenge
he's so surprisingly silly sometimes you
don't really like
he is he's so funny and he's and uh he's
so [ __ ] funny yeah very good dude and
very funny very silly he's got his own
kind of con kind of funny yeah and he
lives yeah and he's so confident and
living in that space man it's kind of um
yeah it's been it's interesting it kind
of gets slowly get to know that guy well
that's what you know it is with you too
it's like you're kind of you you do
you're kind of funny and that's a that's
an interesting thing like when
fines they're like we're talking about
Mitch Hedberg the other day like he had
his kind of funny yeah like you could
see like you could hear Mitch Hedberg
Joe can you go oh that's a that's a
Hedberg joke that's how he does his kind
of funny yeah yeah it's so funny well
thanks for saying that man appreciate
that yeah I think it's like as I've
gotten a little bit older it's made me
feel more comfortable to just be myself
you know you're so long out here I just
felt if I was just afraid to be myself
artists Amy knew who I was you know it's
all those things man you know it's hard
trying to be trying to be confident in
what you're doing is a confidence
destroying way to make a living
yeah you know yeah and I get intimidated
easy like I this is the first time I've
actually felt kind of a little bit more
comfortable being in here really yeah in
here yeah like I don't know it's not you
it's just something with me you know
it's just something I don't know I don't
know if it's like if I feel like if
there's like men that are more like kind
of physically you know in shape or so
just some things maybe inside of me
somewhere that make me feel just on you
know I don't know what it is it's well
people worry about being bullied for
sure people develop like I I feel it
sometimes I'm around big people really
owners to me I was thinking about that
you like hang out around like some real
rare young awesome around some real rare
animal humans you know yes super humans
that Daniel Cormier dude that superhuman
that big coffee John Jones superhuman
yeah Mighty Mouse Amy's a small
superhuman George st. Pierre superhuman
have you ever been like an elevator with
him or something
a bunch of those dudes this guy could
[ __ ] kill me oh they can kill you
anytime they want
you have to deal with that feeling it's
not the best well you're talking to
Francis in Ghana that's always and your
might no matter what you guys are
talking about there's a part of you that
says if you wanted to you could just
kill me like that do you get scared fast
sometimes honestly like I get scared for
you whenever you have to go in the ring
after the fights do you ever get scared
a little bit dude the first time I ever
even interviewed anybody ever after a
fight I had to interview mark coleman
after he choked out dance ever walk and
this was in like UFC [ __ ] 12 so that
was 1997
and Mark Coleman was so fired up max he
just won the heavyweight title [ __ ]
jacked he was so jacked and he was
[ __ ] pumped up and we have no idea
bears in that movie doesn't even he was
the king of the world back then marked
the hammer Coleman changed the [ __ ]
game look at because she was like a real
world-class wrestler taking dudes down
and just smashing them and he was
[ __ ] huge huge you know and so I the
interview first have no idea who I was
[ __ ] is this guy but I have to
respectfully
write him an opportunity to express
himself and then it worked out but I
prepared for that man I was nervous Wow
oh I was nervous that's interesting yeah
cuz it's to me I'm like holy [ __ ] this
guy you know this man is going into the
cage after lunch yep you know that's
what he does how do I want you that's it
I felt like me but like when you go like
you know I'm not a you know these you
know these guys are very some of these
men are very physically imposing to me
like in that you know they're so when
you sometimes I'm like man I can't
believe that you go in there it's just
bravest well now one thing that I think
they all know and if they don't know I
want them to know that I I don't want
anything other than them to shine right
that's all I'm trying to do like when I
interview people what I'm trying to do
is give them an opportunity to talk
about moments I just want to give them a
chance to shine and show who they are I
want them to feel comfortable I look out
for their best interests I really do I
try to do that with commentary even if
it sounds critical my critical
commentary is just expose like I look at
it in terms of I'm looking at it like
it's a math problem or a system and if I
see things I'm like this is this is an
issue even if the person can win with
this issue this is a real issue like a
high-level person's gonna exploit that
issue maybe this guy can't do it but
this sometimes people get upset at that
that does happen but I say listen I have
tics bows and I may be thinking I
exaggerate but believe me those [ __ ]
high class killers that see the same
[ __ ] that I see they're gonna try to
exaggerate that [ __ ] too
that you're gonna try to jump on that
little hole yeah there's a little hole
somewhere and that happens all the time
with people to get mad if you point out
their holes
yeah it doesn't mean they can't win
these guys who've gotten their entire
career they rarely throw a kick they
never submit anybody and there's some of
the best of all time
yeah do you don't have to have a fully
complete game sometimes it's better to
just be ultra good at one or two things
and those other things just don't [ __ ]
with submissions you know just don't
[ __ ] with any of those there's there's
people that are like that they take
someone's back they never choke them
they just keep punching them they never
choke anybody there's a lot of people
like that and then the raccoons almost
raccoons do that you read a record on
you never had a raccoon on me of you oh
yeah they bite you dude if you ever had
one bite you uh if I have one I've had
maybe bite I mean I got scratched or
bitten I mean I had to get all the
rabies shots I mean I grew up in like
the rabies Belt you know so you'd you'd
uh and they group up raccoons to do rec
under they are I can't believe we can't
shut all that [ __ ] down
how many of them are roaming the streets
that know a lot how crazy is it you
stare you down bro you ever seen
Madagascar and they're [ __ ] they're
everywhere did I lived in I lived in New
Rochelle New York and they used to have
these urban raccoon oh yeah different
kind of raccoon raccoons that live in
high-density areas or Boulder species
and they have access to massive amounts
of food they just would lift off the lid
from the garbage can they lift off the
lid they get inside the garbage can they
tear the garbage bags open and they just
be sitting there staring at ya jus
lookin jacked look at gold like they
were big I was like how is that a
raccoon that's a big animal yeah it's
about a blowgun we shoot darts good I
did these [ __ ] would wreck my
garbage and you like [ __ ] over and I'd
be sleeping and I dang look at him
climbing up do we have one is he what is
he doing he's going to get that bird
feeder and unscrew the bird fees bill oh
my God look how smart it is dude this is
insane
oh no smart this thing is but also look
how confident it is in its strength and
look at him
and over the Camry knows he's being
filmed and look how he's yeah I don't
think I knows that but look look how how
good he is it climbing up I mean this is
crazy the amount of physical strength is
[ __ ] has look at this look at that
they let all that seed go and now it's
hanging and partying that raising and
they [ __ ] too - you can hear them at
night we used to live
we used to hear a bunch of them having
sex at night and you could hear you can
go outside and even in a residential
neighborhood dude there's 70 of them on
your block like there's so many raccoons
living amongst us that it's it blows my
mind that it's not a bigger issue pull
that up again look with that video dude
how many people even if they could do
that if they had the kind of strength to
do that how many people would even
figure out how to navigate that so
easily dude Matt Iseman would host this
this is like American Ninja Warrior
dude you telling me that they don't
steal some of these games from this this
is [ __ ] look at him how can we stop
going fullscreen because they were
flirting over I don't know okay when it
goes full screen starts oh I don't know
what the hell is happening look at this
and is that a fake shiner person or
something look at his [ __ ] ability to
just hang on there with one arm and then
grab with his feet that is bananas what
is that called in UFC is that a move no
it doesn't exist
I guess maybe jumped a guard yeah I kind
of jump in two guards look at that it's
amazing like what he can do his little
body is just crazy yeah how much core
strength is a raccoon have to have to do
that
oh dude so much in the garbage it's just
freezing out I have paused on perfect
they can eat newspaper how crazy is that
can they yeah keep going this look at
this but look how comfortable he is just
hanging from its fingers with all four
limbs he's just chilling he's not
worried that something's gonna happen
he's like let me just scoop my ass up
here climb-climb-climb I'm just gonna
twist this [ __ ] off here look at him
he's hanging on with his legs and he
just cracked it open yeah I don't look
at this reverse look at the sucks I'm
gonna buy him at the end but the crazy
thing is he could hold on to that
plastic tube with his hands and feet
like two of each the two of his hands or
two of his feet both their hands look at
the size of their body yeah their hands
this big are tiny can you imagine having
a little bitty baby hand and having to
do something I know right look how much
smaller the hand is in their face you'd
have hands like a four-year-old girl
imagine opening a door but you can't
even open a door you just have to stare
at a doorknob with little but I'm
talking the littlest hands yeah tiny
they'll [ __ ] you up to those things yeah
raccoons eat a lot of chickens too they
like to get into chicken coops [ __ ] up
chickens dude they would jump on your
back it was almost here's the crazy
thing I remember about being around
raccoons it felt like they were playing
with you but it had an immediate
propensity for violence like it could go
like very quick from fun and comfortable
to extremely violent mmm
that makes sense I mean what a
rough-and-tumble world the world of the
vacuum [ __ ] oh you live it right
look at door look at this one okay right
no I think this is it close the door
here and it opens it again my
grandmother had a friend that had a
couple so he just knows how to open
doors
creepy [ __ ] there's something weird
about them mm-hmm it's a strange animal
that like almost seems like it shouldn't
be real you know like a smart weird
animal that lives in the forest like you
expect it to start talking to a little
kid that's on a walk yeah like who are
you where are you from
and it's yeah yeah it's got dice in its
little hand one dice just turns it over
listen your grandmother won't mind if
you hang out with me for a while yeah
come come on I'll show you a house is
made of candy yeah you want some
lipstick they're putting lipstick on
each other creepy animals that's weird
to me the the weirder animals the
animals that have adapted to living
right next to people that's them there
yeah coyotes
that's coyotes that's them will you tell
me about a coyote you had at your house
I've got a bunch of them at my house
they're just in the you know in the
hills if you live anywhere around la in
particular anywhere that there's some
trees and [ __ ] in between the houses
guess what you got coyotes they just
[ __ ] live everywhere man I saw him on
olive in Burbank the other day driving
up olive I saw a [ __ ] coyote so I was
like whoa somebody reported a coyote
fight in my neighborhood when I was
growing up and it was a somebody made
that up but the cops still showed up and
I remember they interviewed everybody
like
[ __ ] knew anything about it dude do
you think coyotes fight wonder if they
do fight with each other
I don't think never heard of them
fighting it must make sense someone has
to be the boss in the coyote world
wolves do wolves [ __ ] each other up
do they really yeah it's awful they kill
each other so these a coyote fights here
most intense coyote fight oh look at
this they're going to war right here
there's a worldstar I think is this
worldstar yes we need to Rob back right
there look at that another one jumped in
three coyotes strategically held by a
bush do you [ __ ] their [ __ ] each
other up dude do you think we could ever
get to the point where you know that
humans fight animals like they did back
in the old days you know like gladiator
style yeah seriously though yeah you
could do that in another country for
sure yeah somebody from some crazy
country where they had some maniacal
dicker dictator who's on crystal meth
and he decided to have humans vs. Lions
give it to a sword and a shield and some
armor and him [ __ ] up a lion 100% do you
think that goes on um I wouldn't say no
yeah because I think there's people with
enough money like [ __ ] crazy crazy
Prince money yeah if there are prints of
some crazy country as people just
probably can't get satisfied it's not
they can't get yeah
cocaine [ __ ] [ __ ] mud hole Jets Oh
Islands in France like what else do I
want what else I want I want to watch a
dude fight a lion with a sword yeah this
is probably like some place that you can
go right and it's got like drains in the
floor where they hose it down from all
the blood and it's like built like a
hockey rink
yeah but the floor underneath the floor
there's a zoo just like they have these
two do it in the Roman days and it rises
up they let the animal out yeah close it
down and then they open the cage and the
[ __ ] dude stands there with the sword
and the crowd goes yeah
and they're all listening to techno
music could speak in Dutch and then that
uh well suddenly we know where they are
that dude in that [ __ ] lion go to war
they go at it man yeah you'd think he
has like face paint on or anything or
he's just mmm it's probably a good move
pull a face paint on you need every edge
yeah you know you gotta fight a line
with a sword you're probably gonna get
killed you're gonna cut the line and
then get killed that's what you're gonna
do give one good hit at it
if you're lucky probably won't even
really yeah yes sword man yeah you you
don't have any idea how slow you are
until you're around a cat that kills
antelopes and [ __ ] chases after
wildebeest takes him out with his face
it's gonna that child you you have no
idea I think everybody no I don't think
you get a shot off I think with the cat
wants to the cats on you so fast you
barely have time to move your arm that's
what I think I don't think yeah yeah I
don't think you have any idea how fast a
like a real predator moves how
ridiculously soft human beings are right
especially if you're not some I don't
[ __ ] Conan the Barbarian dude you can
actually swing a sword a heavy sword
with with some [ __ ] oomph behind it
yeah you ever pick up a real sword it's
heavy [ __ ] man it's [ __ ] heavy and
it's sharp it's almost scary to have one
sometimes you're like [ __ ] I would hurt
myself right cut my cousin up or
something on accident or I'd hurt
somebody at the house yeah the odds of
you killing that lion with one swipe or
almost zero you're gonna get [ __ ] up
okay how would you attack it then say
you're in a place you got this sword
maybe you got one other weapon a small
weapon you keep on your leg or something
the only way that I think you have a
chance is if you can keep your [ __ ]
together
and plunge that blade in its chest as it
leaps on you it's the only way you would
have to be ready to as it comes at you
to push forward and hold on to that
sword with everything you have as it's
coming at you and the blade goes into
its body yeah that might be the only way
and even then it's gonna swat you and
rip you apart you hold on the line
not gonna be able to it's not possible I
think you could do it dude nope nope you
don't think you could no no and you
would keep both hands on now that's how
you acted it out you keep both hands on
it you are not gonna be able to hang on
you're just not it's a different kind of
power it's like the power of many many
men it's like the idea of hey bro do you
think you can win a [ __ ] tug of war
with ten dudes yeah oh yeah bro most
guys are [ __ ] yeah you had a chance
there's there's a strength level you'd
have to be like some Herculean Mariusz
Pudzianowski type dude so I'm just an
enormous [ __ ] World's Strongest Man
guy with chalk all over your hands and a
good grip on the blade and maybe tie it
down like a rodeo rider and plunge it
into the heart of a lion and even then I
don't think you're hanging on to it I
think that thing's gonna buck and kick
and and you're gonna be so terrified and
if it's a male lion you get to see that
Mane in that face and your your body are
you you're gonna get diminished yeah
you're gonna be so overwhelmed with
adrenaline your instincts gonna be to
just run away from that thing as far as
you can you feel like some truths as you
like any truths like any innate truths
would be revealed as you're as you're
sitting here looking to each other's
eyes and you know that it's gonna kill
you I don't think you're even there at
that point I think if you're I think
you're it's such a primal experience
that I think at that point you are
probably the you're barely a human
you're just a series of synapses firing
that are designed to protect you from
predators I think you're just in full
panic full adrenaline rush full survival
mode where you don't you don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on I have some friends
[ __ ] man I got some friends that got
attacked by your hair they got attacked
by a giant grizzly bear and they have
only their know everybody got away
survived luckily but they were in they
were in an island off of Alaska a fog
neck Island and it's a huge population
of brown bears and elk and they all live
together these these [ __ ] bears are
you
in this bear which is like an 11-foot
bear charged into their camp and knocked
everyone over like guys were flying left
and right one of the dudes his nicknames
dirt myth
dirt myth was riding on the things back
if you want to hear the whole story and
it's a great story go to the meat-eater
podcast and I think the episodes just
say a fog nack Island I don't know if it
says bear attack on a fog nack Island
but if you're us if you're a clever
Googler you'll find it's a great podcast
anyway Steve Bernal is a genius he's a
really interesting guy and a hunter like
we just totally totally defies the
stereotype that people have of like
doofy hunters like super well read
really interesting guy but his depiction
of this event the most striking thing
about it was that it defied everything
that he thought it would be like if
there was an actual bear attack sounds
like Hemingway asked almost in a weird
way
well no we're right yeah because when
look if something really [ __ ] crazy
happens the best-case scenario is there
someone who actually knows how to write
that's right there when there's
something crazy happened right and this
is the case but instead of writing it he
just does a very eloquent job of
describing it as does everybody else
there I mean it was quite a few guys
there my friend Remy Warren was there
and Yanis patellas this is one where
they got false attacked this was in
British Columbia they got false charged
a false charge is a bear this in this
case it was a bear with Cubs and she
just wanted to scare them off so she
came running at them full clip it's
crazy to see because they fired near her
but they had the discipline to not fire
at her well I'm like that is really
impressive because this thing just came
[ __ ] running at them and it's huge
like here it is like give me some volume
here
oh my god
peels off man is away and Callahan says
I'll never forget I want to give him a
t-shirt with him in his mustache and
this says smell us now 80 fellas now
lady that's the sentence that comes to
callaghan's mind this so that is what he
had experienced before and so he kind of
kept his composure in that situation and
he's like this other one where the
grizzly bear literally knocked them over
to the teeth word gnashing 10 inches
from his face it was just so many people
the grizzly probably didn't expect there
to be that many people there there was
like seven people there please let me
think how many people one two
at least five people there and I think
that's what saved it even though there's
camera people too is it probably was
about seven people and I think that's
what saved them the fact that this was a
giant mass of people and the bear didn't
know which way to go and one of the
dudes Yanis hit it in the face with
trekking poles
you know those trekking poles yeah it
was right they smacked in the face and
the thing veered off one of the guys
Remy he juked it he faked right and then
went left the bear it was just so much
going on the bear just ran through it
one of the guys wound up on the Bears
bag for like ten yards
the bear was running and he was somehow
under stuck on the Bears back and then
fell off this is how big the bear was
and yeah I think when you see a bear man
you don't think it's gonna be like that
that intense you know you don't think it
because the first picture they showed of
that bear he seemed like a calm bear you
know look at that bear I've seen him in
and the worst thing about bears is they
advertise them mostly Disney movies how
do you see a bear teddy bear you know
what I'm saying
you know they have [ __ ] bears [ __ ]
- on the internet they have all that
kind of [ __ ] but it mostly sweeties do
your buddy there your buddy
meanwhile how about those little kids
that their dad got eaten in front of
them those little kids what if they had
a little pet polar bear
that's not outside the realm of
possibility with little kids and you you
get convinced that that's what those
animals are look I'm not saying you
should never pet
stuff polar bear they're cute it's not
bad but you know I'm saying a toy would
you have a little bear you think they'll
go as a pet no [ __ ] way man really is
ridiculous you seem like a guy that
might have a little bit [ __ ] that dude
[ __ ] that first of all they're not
listening to you yeah get away with all
that there might be your friend it might
be a friend as they grow older but you
better keep that food around [ __ ] and
even if you have that food around you
can't keep them from killing other
people like there was a guy who has bear
trained look at the size of that [ __ ]
oh my god this guy is definitely
probably oh my god this is a gay guy if
you keep this animal fed there are
people that have bears this isn't Russia
this is Russia yeah so if there's people
that keep bears fed and take care of
them and treat them well you know and
this is the thing about bears - is that
bears are omnivores they eat everything
oh really ate animals ate vegetables
they eat everything
yeah it's crazy they like people in a
lot of way
in that their you know their diet varies
so they don't have to eat they don't
have to kill things they don't
necessarily have the desire to chase
things down and kill things like a cat
does like cats have a deep desire to
kill things right like cats can't shake
that [ __ ] yeah I think you could you
could feed a bear well and take care of
it and you could probably avoid most of
that but if it ever feels threatened in
any way you're so [ __ ] and do you
think you have any like there you might
not even notice when that bear feels
that way well I wouldn't I'm not a bear
expert I think a real bear expert would
see that something's weird the Bears
acting sketchy yeah they're bears like
yeah they just they start acting
irritated look at the size of these
things man this guy is definitely a
pervert you think so
yeah because I think there's got to be
something inside of you that gets off in
a weird way to do this I don't think
this feels natural I think they're
intoxicated by powerful animals and not
having these powerful animals around
gives them a thrill okay the thrill has
to be do you think that that they could
kill them that's it 100% and also they'd
like the thrill is they are beautiful
creatures so you do want to be around
them like they're cool to just be around
and you can make friends with
beautiful creature that could just kill
a mass of people it kind of feels fun
dangerous yeah it's cool too feels
dangerous it's like a celebrity it's
like knowing Elton John or some way
better you know pet grizzly come over my
house [ __ ] I got a 12-foot dog
it was my house you know like but cats
see that's all that no more loose these
people these are different animals this
is a different thing but I think if
people have an animal like that they're
[ __ ] next to it at night and they're
doing I think is some of that I think
you should be yeah probably
near it I don't think they're getting
involved with them but I think they're
doing near it but hooting [ __ ] right
next to the tiger and get them horny
well dude bestiality needs a different
because I thought this about bestiality
I don't know if we've even talked about
this like but if you have sex with a
local animal some that lives your house
livestock right chickens so my phone
it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up and it's
not you know it's you know we're
traveling overseas with the specific
intention of having sex with an animal
okay that's to me that feel [ __ ] up
you know the rules are different I don't
know you ask Bobby locally I'm sure in
some places they're like give me some
money now you do whatever you want that
I go you know but if you if you [ __ ] a
mountain lion that's a strong man that's
how I that's it young dude you never buy
a beer again you [ __ ] a mountain you
[ __ ] link yeah that to me that's not
bestiality to me that's like some Ragnar
lothbrok type [ __ ] yeah that's the
bravest thing you can do that's a Viking
[ __ ] imagine a trying to keep an
erection and then sneak up on a [ __ ]
animals but you'd have to you have to
figure out a way to hold them down do
you think there's ever guy the best of
the mount line then [ __ ] it see I see
another I believe there might be another
Theo von or an infinite number of them
out in the universe talking to another
me and that we're sitting in the exact
same to the exact same notes I believe
that I'm not sure I believe any of those
people on any of those planets planets
ever [ __ ] a mountain lion I don't a
long time ago you don't think that one
no but there's no YouTube there's nobody
that's the only person who knows is the
other two people people gonna think
they're lying probably cuz they're
alcoholics you could fall eat I don't
think so dude I don't think there's any
squirrels or rape people either you know
and I think I think it's that that's
more likely it's more likely that a
squirrel would rape a person I could see
it's gonna [ __ ] someone who's drunk who
passed out in their yard that's more
likely okay I go crazy super horny
squirrel just can't keep it together he
keeps [ __ ] up yeah some Kappa deltas
just passed out under [ __ ] yard you
know crazy I do not think that a guy
could [ __ ] a mountain lion I just don't
think that's ever happened especially
not gay sex right maybe a female
mountain lion might let you she's all
wild up and in heat and he my friend
wasn't it Chris Ryan talked about
[ __ ] his cat with a pencil that's
right you did that's that's his shirt he
tells a great story about his cat was in
heat and she backed up to him she's like
trying to get some dick and he put a
pencil in there it he was like a little
kid he was like a little good yes chéri
was an adult sexual experience was this
cat healing backing up on this pencil
yeah I should imagine that did I
remember getting like an erection and
just I remember his hot hold it against
[ __ ] did I remember being at the
library when I was young and this is
back when they had books you know what
do they have now um you know I mean I'm
like [ __ ] or libraries still open
who's hitting here because people's
around a finger each book about homeless
people they allow homeless people in
libraries yeah can we just start calling
them shelters you know what I'm saying
and serve lunch but I remember going in
there and the only sex you could see at
the time was like rode in or something
like that or these old artists remember
they were paying like a rubenesque home
by shooting at you bit like this yeah
see breasts did you'd have one of her
hands like this hands why is that
but I remember why is that like a pose
it's indicative of a certain time and
history yes because it's [ __ ] really
hard to draw a hand oh that could be it
maybe somebody drew warning but you you
think that like Emperor's would stand
there and do this to their to their
people yeah like you know how great look
there's two things that Trump could do
that people would freak the [ __ ] out one
of them obviously is like a Sieg Heil
yeah that's bad the other one that might
be just as bad as the Emperor yeah he
comes out with one hand almost like he's
holding an invisible football and the
other hand do this and just address the
people people who blow a gasket
oh my god dude he should start wearing a
crown how great would it be if he
started wearing a crown dude it would be
hilarious if we started wearing like a
cheap burger do you think you think he
has a sense of humor he definitely does
yeah he definitely is the first
president that has ever been roasted on
Comedy Central oh that's a great point
dude he got roasted on Comedy Central
and Jeff Ross even said to him like like
you're not laughing at the jokes like
you should probably laugh at them like
don't don't it's probably people like it
better if you you're going along with
these yeah yeah you're right and then he
loosened up and started laughing at so
he like takes advice from people right
that are in the business
they told some ruthless jokes about him
man oh yeah
you hung in there he handled it oh I
think he's resilient whether or not he
can feel any of that like cuz of his
like whatever ego spaces and I wonder
how much that even feels but I'm only he
might be the only human in America that
could take this much hatred from people
at such like a level dude that brush put
it on yeah and it doesn't sit off care
it's weird yeah it's all I mean it's
[ __ ] it's kind of awesome it's kind
of oh I remember after he got elected
driving down the street me and like holy
[ __ ] dude I could be President [ __ ]
yeah that was what we thought when we
were kids - what's awesome about his and
when I say awesome I don't mean good I
mean amazing about his abilities like
all throughout all this crazy [ __ ] he
doesn't show any signs of being like he
doesn't seem to be like freaked out
right over the stormy Daniel [ __ ] or
over the rushing all the investigations
occasionally he goes on a mad tweet
storm yeah he seems to be the same guy
right he was before it doesn't seem to
be there's certain dudes
when you see something like was a good
example something [ __ ] up happens to
them and you see it in their face rice
like they're like well like George Bush
whenever maybe on that video in the 911
ever they see the pictures and they told
him about not well 9/11 was huge thing
that's I don't think he knew how huge it
was at the time it was all breaking out
you know the that was a bad example yeah
but yeah Trump says this seems totally
unaffected he's just crazy
no more senior citizens on Twitter that
that's the thing senior citizens on
Twitter is kind of bizarre oh there's a
lot of them now yeah they love crazy
will they take a break every couple
minutes of doing Facebook all day
yelling at people on Facebook everybody
hates the guy so I don't think
everybody's I think a lot of people like
the time we're in right now because it's
so it's just I feel like you know what
you're gonna get
you know ya know it's it's a strange
time for communication man it really is
yeah strange time for everything yeah
man it's uh it's different it's so
different to it it's [ __ ] it's kind of
fascinating I had dumb they got Jordan
Peterson came out on podcast yeah came
on your podcast yeah which was wild cuz
I'd know his publicist and I reached out
and the publicist and then it was wild
and so then he came through because I
mean a lot of the people listen to my
podcasts her you know we talked a lot
about like being sober and like people
that masturbate too much kind of weird
stuff you know troubled youths kind of
I'll say it right um but anyway it was
cool because he like I don't know you
know him better than I do him he loves
you he said a lot of nice things about
oh that's nice he's a great guy he's
really misunderstood man misrepresented
people think he sunk some fascists and
some Nazi I didn't think that at all
he's not by any stretch of the
imagination he just says certain things
that people are uncomfortable hearing
and whether you agree with them or
disagree with them that's one thing but
that's the demonization is where it gets
weird even if you think he's what his
ideas foolish don't misrepresent who he
is as a person
yeah they try to pretend that he's this
racist homophobic [ __ ] alt-right
character he's not by any stretch of the
imagination he's just a guy that
especially when his principles are being
debated or when his ideas are
like he'll stand his ground and he's
very firm about what he thinks is wrong
about things like equality of outcome
like making sure that everybody makes
the same amount of money make sure
everybody achieves the same amount of
success like that is a ridiculous idea
that leads to communism and Marxism he
gets into it and it made me rethink how
I thought about it before then I thought
about it before then like an
unattainable goal that socialist leaned
towards because it's like the ideal the
ideal is that money's not a concern for
anybody and everybody just sort of does
whatever they want to do because they
enjoyed doing it not because they're
doing it for money and that all the
money's kind of piled in together and we
take care of everybody it sounds great
on paper right but then he starts
talking about no you have to enforce the
equality of outcome right he goes when
you were talking about acquit there's
gonna be people that work harder right
it's gonna be male that try harder
there's gonna be different varying
levels of effort because we're human
beings you have to take that into
consideration as these people don't take
that into consideration
it's then you're you're you're either
trying to stop the people that are doing
too well or you're trying to take from
them to give to yourself and how are you
enforcing this and he just takes you
down this rabbit hole of thought and
really kind of explains the problems
with Marxism and socialism and I'm sure
there's really intelligent people that
dispute his ideas I'm not saying that
his ideas are infallible or that he's
the only voice that I would listen to in
these subjects but he's a brilliant guy
and he's a very nice guy too and he's
really missing misrepresented and and
willfully so a lot I think it's sad
because I think what's missing between
right and the left is how much of it we
would probably agree on we just talk
about things rationally instead of
contentiously instead of getting into
these right versus left to base which
are just way too common yeah where
everybody's on one side is trying to
diminish the person in this side and and
get angry and they're doing a lot of
these in front of big crowds which i
think is also weird because then you're
playing to the crowd I've seen some
things that Jordan did with this Michael
Eric Dyson guy with a guy literally
wasn't looking at him is looking at the
crowd calling him a mean mad white man
and it's like right these kind of things
that people are doing it's just
everyone's just digging their heels in
deeper on each side and instead of like
looking at life like just having an open
conversation about things
that are troubling things where we could
do better things where society needs
work or things maybe where our
perceptions are off and maybe we could
look at the other side or look at each
other but look at the whole thing better
and figure out a better way around
things instead of doing that everybody's
just right versus left and right and
deeper in the trenches and harder and we
got a stop drop and I hope we have a
recession to stop Trump and people are
saying crazy [ __ ] crazy look everybody's
supposed to suffer so that you can make
one guy feel like he's doing a bad job
or it's just not the way to approach it
like you've seen that what does that
woman's name Maxine what is her name
Maximus or Trump I call her dark Trump
she's people she's wild people to
interrupt people's meals and and draw a
crowd and like you know and I guess it's
in response to what is the most
disturbing policy was to separate
children from their parents and people
that are crossing the border but I think
he didn't he decide to put a stop to
that didn't they decide to put a stop to
that did he sign something to put a stop
to that well it's definitely scary if
you're doing that new border I don't I
don't know let's find out what the [ __ ]
that means
you know we would have I know do that
and I mean how do you separate people
from their kids you've got to be you got
to be trying to send some fucked-up
message to scare the [ __ ] out of them so
that'll keep them from coming over this
is the idea I guess if you tell them
you're gonna take their kids away they
probably won't even try and then but
what about this say if like you know
everybody's against like sex trafficking
and I'm not like what if one of those
people is that scenario and the kids too
afraid to say it I know that's like
maybe more in acute situation but in
that case you'd be grateful that you
separated them at least to get each of
them's point of view to know kind of
what's a little bit more what's going on
apparently that's like a huge issue like
apparently sex trafficking
you know everybody's just bringing young
women in here too
you know from other places for sex and I
don't see that much of it but apparently
it's the biggest thing in the world you
know or it was last month well there was
something that was I don't know this is
true either
I'm giving Jamie a lot of work today
there was a smart there right sex
trafficking ring that was
broken up by ice and outside of it these
people were protesting ice because of
what I they were like saying abolish ice
but meanwhile ice was like stepping they
didn't understand that when you're doing
what is it image immigrations Customs
Enforcement is that what I stands for
what they're doing is not just they're
not just trying to stop people from
crossing over the border they're also
busting in this case apparently it was a
sex trafficking or a human trafficking
ring I don't know if they were using
them as slaves or if they're using them
as sex slaves
well that's the thing say if say if two
truckloads of people come into America
right and one is you know adults and
children and another as adults and
children right and one of them are just
actual family members and one of them
are sex you know adults you know
Manman trying to bring in sex workers we
let's yeah we don't I mean how do you
know how do you not set you know like I
know yeah you don't want to take a
mother from a kid or a father from a
daughter but it's like how do you know
what if we and what if you don't you
know I don't know it's well that is the
problem with people coming in if they're
coming in illegally you have no idea who
they are what they're doing yeah I mean
that's that's only one problem the other
problem is people who are criminals
people who are violent offenders you
know people there's people that have
gotten back and forth multiple times and
got busted in American wound up killing
people that happened many times yeah
they're that guy in San Francisco I
remember that I simile shot yeah
shooting the girl but yeah I mean it's
you know I'm glad I mean I as much as
it's hectic sometimes to think about it
in here about it I think it's also it's
neat to be alive at a time when you know
I'm challenged to think you know and I'm
challenged to to to feel different ways
and to hear different voices and
opinions about it honestly like I feel
like we should have more of a roll call
in America like you have to know who's
here before you can even you know like
if you're teaching a classroom people
know who's in the class how can you even
you know you know but it's what they
should do first and foremost is legalize
drugs and the reason being is that
they're getting across from organized
crime and it's building organized crime
and
Mexico to a staggering degree the drugs
are here people are selling these drugs
period they're going to keep selling
these drugs
you're not gonna diminish the amount of
drugs you just not yeah no one's ever
been able to do it the drug wars are
complete total failure hope they love
coke
so make coke legal you would put a
[ __ ] halt to so much and if you made
coke legal people would die
pure coke you would it would it be
tested and you you could give people
drug education cuz like everybody knows
okay how many beers can you drink if you
drink three beers you probably shouldn't
drive a car unless you're a giant you
know like three beers you're probably
over the legal limit you're a bear right
unless just some 7-foot tall
gorilla type man who's just got a lot of
by but a regular regular guy beers you
should not drive right so now stop and
think like what is the level for cocaine
I don't know I don't do it I've never
done it but I don't know what it is like
maybe we should know like you know you
can't have three shots of Jack Daniels
and drive okay but what what about what
about speed I'm like you take two lines
of coke you should not be talking to
people yeah should be [ __ ] calling an
architect
dude one of my buddies tried to put all
of his fingers in his but one time I
forget like an eight ball of coke how
crazy is that so good goal but look and
it's hard and it's nice to have a name
for what was that called fingers in your
boy yeah it's called something it was
like called a clapper the Liberty Bell
or something some crazy thing but um
Jamie's Google when you have all your
fingers in your butt I think that's go
go for hunt have to be like bunny style
and to be super flexible pull it off and
you're gonna the crazy part is and I'm
just I'm thought about this a lot but I
have thought about this for a little bit
you're gonna start with your smallest
fingers and then you're gonna be stuck
with those thumbs that's gonna be trying
oh yeah that's gonna be the hard part
you're gonna rip your [ __ ] yeah well
that's the risk you take like an old
balloon
it's exciting that thing you know
there's no there has to be some risk of
rewarding it your friend must have
slender fingers well he was farming look
dude he's on that much cocaine did I'll
do it you know I used to that's the
thing dude I got all [ __ ] up and you
know I used to get cocaine and do it by
myself at home you know just to I don't
know I wasn't doing that good just have
some feelings and I remember
dude I would order vests and [ __ ] off
the internet I have like what kind of
vests oh all kinds like the kind that we
would wear if you lived in Boulder with
them down filled ones Patagonia yeah I'm
done I've gone that's a weird look yeah
you got the flannel shirt with the puffy
vest yeah
very common look but it's like what are
we doing here well I want to be warm but
I want to let a little bit of
ventilation in my arms just a little
chill don't want around my body no I
like my torso to be warm I'm talking all
kinds bro I will get the leather I would
get the ones with the bead what I mean I
have like uh honestly I probably about
30 best at home why vests why was that
the thing that you would order on
cocaine it was just something I like to
do with my belt buckles you have any
preposterous belt buckles huh like some
that light up different colors and [ __ ]
like yeah I'm going out with this one of
my buddies had a belt buckle said [ __ ]
only on it oh nice yeah that guy's gay
100% gay he's a kid no [ __ ] what about
you [ __ ] no [ __ ] bro you know what I
do when I get [ __ ]
no what do you do I'll show you bro take
your pants off I'm just an so was a
[ __ ] be careful he's like yeah I got a
labia tattoo a mass love it push it
I got vulva tattooed on my back in AH in
Old English letters bro I love puts you
so much I had my [ __ ] turned into a
[ __ ] yeah yeah go ahead [ __ ] it put
your feels just like the real thing
put eight and a half of your fingers in
it bro they use stem cells bro yeah I
got some new stem cells dude I got these
new stem cells used on my [ __ ] um but
uh but that guy yes yeah I don't know
but they got Jordan Peters from a super
cool man what did you guys talk about
you said you listened to any of his
stuff before you got him on
yep I listened to your episode with him
actually from the day before and I
listened to and I'd been listening to
his book so that's where I was and I
listened to the monk debate the monk
debates are the ones where the guy
called him a mad white man I was like
this so silly
but I found him to be and this just uh
he just seemed like the pure he seemed
completely pure and whatever you know he
believed I think that in helping people
like because I talked to him about like
did he start to feel like famous you
know like because people are really
gravitating toward ya and he just felt
it genuinely seemed that he felt just
good for people he won he was happy to
be helping others and that like it
didn't seem like he had any ego in it he
he definitely does like to help people
but he also feels a responsibility
because of his knowledge to explain what
he thinks is a problem with certain
types of behavior certain laws and one
of them that got him in trouble or got
him controversial got a lot of
controversy attached to it was the
compelled speech laws for transgender
people the use of compelled pronouns me
know Indiana death yeah so if you
decided that you weren't gonna be a he
or a she you could make up a number of
different names and they would be
legally compelled to use those names and
some people are arguing that's not what
it says and then he was saying no it's a
it's a human rights violation if you
don't follow along with that like this
is this is compelled speech and this is
dangerous because this is why this is
what it leads to
and then there's all these people
debating with them but then what you got
a chance to see is with him debating
these points with these various
intellectuals including like gender
studies teachers and [ __ ] you got to see
like oh this this is a crazy idea like
these these people that think that you
should have like 78 different gender
pronouns and then it's it's tantamount
to violence to not use someone's
preferred pronoun you're like oh oh
you're crazy
right oh this is a mad person who wants
the world to be different so you want
all these new laws attached to whether
or not someone calls them and he or she
yeah and they're getting some traction
with it what is weird in New York New
York City I think it's landlords
and it might be employers might but I
think of pretty sure it's landlords they
are compelled to use your preferred
pronoun hmm so if your landlord decides
to call you a different thing like if
you say a machine now and it's like [ __ ]
you Thea I knew you when you were Thea
you're Theo see what that law is
compelled gender pronouns law New York
City but but people like wait a minute
wait a minute how many do I have to know
right which ones do I have to agree with
yeah you start because there's a ton of
them now this literally is 78 different
gender pronouns you know what I'm
finding like I know they would you know
for a while it was like people in
certain areas they don't want to build
transgender bathrooms it's like because
there's nine people in this town yeah
and we've seen everybody's dick like
nobody we don't have any you can't
change all these zoning laws for people
for when there's not even someone
present in some of these areas I think
in some bad ways they're making people
not be accepting of transgender people
that they may meet at some point right
by creating all of this this this this
rhetoric or whatever it is this this
conversation it's like some people are
already fed up and they've never even
met someone like this and so then
they're gonna have weird they're gonna
have already like contentious views when
they do meet someone just cuz they've
heard so much background noise that it's
problematic you know when it's not
that's certainly possible it's also
possible that people will be scared of
the backlash so they won't use
transphobic language anymore
the problem with that is you're not
encouraging empathy you're encouraging
fear you're encouraging fear of not
following the the standard line of
behavior and speech yeah and that's
where people have a problem with it it's
like the real way to do it is to promote
empathy to say like look these people
like this guy's born in the wrong body
yeah came a woman he went through the
surgery let him use the woman's room
yeah like why not and if they're a bad
person judge that bad person on each
individual basis now when you're talking
about children that's what people are
scared of yeah you know you're gonna
have some creep who pretends he's a
woman so he can get in the girls room
and he's gonna molest children those are
those worst-case scenarios yeah
those are terrible worst-case scenarios
but what how often is that gonna happen
how do we protect that how we prevent
that from happening though those are the
questions but what for the vast majority
of the people that become trans do you
really think they're gonna molest people
I don't think they are you can't judge
the vast majority based on a few that's
just like the same logic that says
people shoot up people with guns so we
should take everyone's guns away that's
crazy to know the vast majority of
people with guns don't shoot people the
vast majority people were trans they
don't hurt anybody the nothing that all
they're trying to do is just get along
and be who they are this is a complex
subject I think the danger is when
people are scared that they're scared or
bullied into agreeing with one side of
the other side because then then [ __ ]
gets weird because then it becomes a
battle but it becomes a battle instead
of an opportunity yeah a discussion an
opportunity to enforce and encourage
compassion like that it can be done both
ways yeah I think the Opera but to look
at these people like look they just okay
why do you care if someone wants to be a
girl why do you care if she wants to be
a guy why do you care yeah like let him
do it
let him be free let me there themselves
just like let it do tattoo his face
let let what do whatever you want man as
long as you're not [ __ ] people over
and you're not hurting people you know
they're robbing people and stealing from
people and murdering people as long as
that's not happening yeah do whatever
you want yeah that should be our
approach this stuff that's me one of our
that should be someone the Bill of
Rights or somewhere I knew what new a
new amendment should be something in
there where we think about the why why
we have a problem and how we address the
problem as soon as you address the
problem with force force forward is
force in return you're gonna get forced
back people are gonna get they're gonna
want to get ramped up just as much to
attack you as you attack them and then
you're going back and forth left and
right and it becomes [ __ ] chaos yeah
that's what we have right now and you
see the difference between Fox News and
CNN and the right and the left and
everybody digs their heels and fat and
[ __ ] it's it's not it's not helpful it's
not helpful and there's also a bunch of
people that profit off of this this
battle and you okay no New York City did
not
just introduced a $250,000 fine for any
incorrect use of gender pronouns but
they did for some use of gender pronouns
I think the question misinterpretation
of a guideline that's already existed
there was a blog post I got written in
the New York Post reported on it
there was a updated or a change in the
guidelines but it's not supposed to be
free like an incorrect or miss misuse of
it what is it supposed to be for
harassment discrimination and things
like that
okay so regardless of individual sex
assigned at birth Anatomy gender medical
history appearance or the sex indicated
on the individuals identification okay
the raw requires employers and covered
entities to use an individual's
preferred name pronoun in title eg
misses or mrs. regardless of the
individuals sex assigned at birth so
that's it okay these guidelines as noted
by the Commission can impose penalties
of up to $250,000 for violations that
are the result of willful wanton or
malicious conduct mm-hmm so that seems
like they're saying that it is true
there are that is the so there is a law
but there's a commission it's not just
like you can't just say it no but
someone's gonna find you it has to go
through a long lengthy court process
they're not just finding people like
businesses and like can you imagine the
G all this is gonna do is create a ton
of lawsuits yeah just because it's a
commission like that that might even be
worse that you're bringing it into like
you have to sit in front of a bunch of
experts who have to decide whether or
not you you misgendered someone or
gestapo-like it's crazy it's crazy to me
just look if someone's an [ __ ]
they're an [ __ ] like what if so what
if you're a Jew and someone calls you a
[ __ ] can they get fined $250,000 how
does that work well no right but that's
an offensive term for a Jewish person
right so if you if you brought that to
court how would that work you I don't
think you get it right it's Commission
though a business being brought they're
not like just a price yeah like
landlords is one of them that they
brought up like you know
if you decided that you were be Jamie
still but now you're Jamie the woman I'm
like the [ __ ] out of here Jamie
you're a dude give me my money yeah
that's like a Missy wouldn't they if if
that was the case it was and I wanted an
apartment that you were offering and you
wouldn't give me an apartment for that
reason huh or we work together in some
sort of way and I'm discriminating
against you at work ma'am b/c it's just
so it's feel like so many it just seems
like a ground for so many lawsuits what
I find is if somebody's a dick to
somebody if somebody's calling somebody
a name or something these days with so
many camera phones and so many things
usually it gets brought out pretty quick
if somebody's racist these days like
really devout like in their core and
they do like it gets brought out pretty
[ __ ] quick yeah not always though not
always I'm sure some people get away
with it well you know you learn you know
how I learned like in in the area I grew
up in not to be racist you'd hear
somebody say something to somebody else
that they shouldn't say and they got
their ass whooped and then they learned
not they I mean it was a weird way to
learn it but you learned you learned it
would be nice if people could learn
another way to realize how stupid it is
to just be racist yeah there's three
ways you should judge individuals like
based on their actions and what they've
done how they treat other people how you
know whether or not they're doing things
that are illegal or immoral or unethical
that's as an individual but as soon as
you're doing it based on where they
can't control right there what they're
what they look like where they were born
what part of the world they're from
that's just [ __ ] stupid it's just a
stew it's you you're you're you're
judging people on something of zero
control over yeah you have any control
over your color that's crazy and if
there's people that are still doing that
that are still living in that space then
it's I mean it is something that I think
someone will just take more time but I
think eventually some that will be
eradicated
I think it's beige powers my thing what
we're all gonna be beige bro you know
I'm saying we're three general
generations from all being bathed yeah
II think so you don't know no not
because of places like England and
Scotland and Ireland where it's always
raining you're gonna just gonna get a
massive amount of white people in those
spots no matter what it's there's no Sun
you went white brown people that move
there of five six seven generations
they start paling up like Brendan Schaub
see settings from England that's what it
really he lies about a lot dude for me I
think he does you don't he just forgets
things yeah a black guy from England
like 500 years ago is full families
probably black and then over time over
time they just turned into white people
just like every other person that moved
to England yeah right every [ __ ]
human being came out of Africa a hundred
percent yeah that's the the origin of
the species we came from Africa we
branched out into the world and we got
to places like Scotland where it never
[ __ ] sits never sunny and we got
bleached out people got they turned into
like solar panels for vitamin D and the
soak up that vitamin D yeah because if
you're black like you got so much
melanin oh yeah if you're like Congo
black you've got a dark skin color
that's just awesome for Sun but it's
terrible when there's no Sun like how
you getting your vitamin D dude even if
you hug a black person I think your skin
feels a little bit kind of like more
moist you know what I'm saying kind of
these cocoa butter yeah remember Ashley
oh dude we had a dude in our
neighborhood his brother set him on fire
and his whole leg was ass she just dude
booboo Tyson and he does anything just
roll on oh yeah she's just dry skin but
sometimes I feel a little bit of African
like in my course unless I'll lay in bed
at night and just like pretend I was in
Africa never get your blood tested to
see what you are yeah I didn't look at
the result yet
didn't look at the results and I'm
scared what you might be I don't want to
be French that's what I don't want to be
honestly you I think you're French no
I'm not do I see French a little bit
yeah I think you got 13% don't laugh
about that Jamie what how come you don't
want to be French of all things what's
wrong with that why would that bother
you even a little bit
they made great wine great painters who
create a rewind they came laying a lot
yeah apparently they like to [ __ ] really
yeah that's the word that French people
just like to [ __ ] and they think that
the way we handle things is stupid like
they have affairs like openly publicly
like a little bit politicians they of
course they cheat they're all [ __ ]
animals over there
and that Toxoplasma apparently was
running rapid through friends really
yeah what is it
Toxoplasma is that things yet from cats
get it and they get it from rats and
it's a it's a parasite that gets into
human brains and it affects humans and
it makes people a little bit more
reckless like rabies kind of a light no
not rabies more like like slightly drunk
all the time yeah and this Toxoplasma
apparently there was at one point in
time 40% of ever inch of France was
infected with Toxoplasma yeah see if you
find that that's true that's been a [ __ ]
fast I bet [ __ ] fest wild and loose yeah
you got JP they think that there there's
a direct correlation between the high
levels of infestation and the behavioral
changes of the population infestation of
what rats and stuff know of this
Toxoplasma apparently 50 million people
in this country have it you get it from
cat [ __ ] or from if you live in a farm
like you step on a field and it gets in
your skin like maybe cats
I've been [ __ ] all over the place or
a dog will eat something that you know
some catch and when you get [ __ ]
your feel around the dog 2012 analysis
from France where an estimated 43
percent of the people carrying
toxoplasmosis Gandhi concluded that men
with a latent infection tend to be more
dogmatic less confident more jealous
less impulsive and more orderly than
uninfected men infected women seem
warmer more conscientious more
persistent more insecure and more
sanctimonious whoa dude I'll get a
six-pack for the ladies then huh that's
not crazy is that that 43% of people
carry it Jesus Christ that's a large
number of human beings infected by
something that changes behavior or at
least leads to trends that are different
hmm and noticeable more dogmatic less
confident less confident is interesting
that gondii toxoplasmosis gondii
associations of having antibodies to the
parasite with bipolar disease suicidal
behavior even optimistic disposition
possibly related to the Paris
its effect on dopamine so it gets in
your body and then you just have it for
life
oh wow yeah it sexually transmitted it
must be then huh that's a good question
that's a very good question I don't know
if 42% of people have it I can't imagine
that half of the population is
stepped-on up
you know [ __ ] well I think they
that's a good question that's a good
question but I think there's a lot of
feral cats around yeah that's true yeah
I think when this place is like Elgato
yeah we had a lot of feral cats running
around ratatouille they have that whole
movie about that animal it was shut up
yeah and what it does to the rats is it
makes them get hard-ons when they smell
cat piss
is that really yep rewires their sexual
reward system so lately their testes
enlarged when they smell cat piss no
they get hard [ __ ] a neighbour like
that with pregnancy
say that's their past through pregnancy
to the child yeah woof woof there you go
ruff 43% so high number that's a it's
like it's a lot of people it's 43 out of
a hundred people do 2 billion people on
the planet 2 billion people have it yes
43 percent of those tested in that study
and that's all the people to get tested
who the [ __ ] I've never been tested
you've been tested know how many people
been tested that's a rough estimate man
they don't [ __ ] know I bet it's a lot
higher I bet as a lot of people that
have it yeah [ __ ] in the blood dude I
probably got it we had dr. Robert
Sapolsky in the podcast we did one with
him he's an expert in it and he's got a
bunch of lectures and speeches on it and
he said that when he was a resident then
he had heard about a guy who found out
that a disproportionate number of
motorcycle accidents were attributed to
people that were on this Toxoplasma
really yeah that they that they they got
this infection and it was causing them
to do stupid [ __ ] on motorcycles and
crash I would hate that man it's hard
enough to ride a motorcycle and then
have like you know just to be being led
astray by a rare disease in your brain a
1 and I wonder if it varies right I
wonder if the Toxoplasma that they get
in Paris has the same exact response as
the one that they get inside the
variation no just America the field is a
bunch of variation yeah Oh see that's
what I'm talking about
different ones a Long Island has a lot
of Jesus Christ there's different ones
[ __ ] see I bet the what is this though
this seem like what is it well it's
parasites okay so we have our sites
parasites exist in so many animals they
hitch rides and then that they've that's
their ecosystem our ecosystems to be on
planet Earth their ego system is to be
in Planet Theo von and they just get
inside of you have parasites ever change
like the kind of the course of history
is that what happened with the plague or
is that a different thing
no the plague is a different thing but
they probably could change the course of
history if they really changed that many
people's behavior if you think about
Paris
there are France they're talking about
43 percent of the people have this
infection the irony of parasites how
crazy is that that's crazy
it's a parasite what if they have could
you imagine little French [ __ ] Berets
yeah we go behavior stupid Americans the
craziest one man is this aquatic worm it
climbs inside a grasshoppers body grows
in the grasshoppers body and then it
tells the grasshopper to commit suicide
oh my god so it gets the grasshopper to
jump into the water and then once the
grasshopper gets in the water then it
bursts out of its body well it's like
Pinocchio meet some alien if you see a
movie alien Sigourney Weaver it is like
Pinocchio it's like the bottom of the
whale right belly of the whale yeah
movie alien with Sigourney Weaver
probably my favorite science fiction
movie of all time oh really
yeah I would say if I had to pick one
science fiction horror movie that was
like filled one I would say that alien
it's kind of cornball when you watch the
special effects now though yeah like not
as scary yeah there's some space stuff
that you like oh okay this is 1978 you
forget different I wasn't even 1980 man
you know that's corny that's crazy hot
as hyzer being he was tall and she had
curly hair I remember thinking about
strong confident sexy yes like her
[ __ ] neck wanted and like you think
he couldn't choke her out yeah like if
she was she was a power
woman like this isn't a woman that needs
a man right if she liked you it's like
oh she's like I'm worthy
yeah of her like she drove a van but
because she had [ __ ] business to do
yeah I think we should have like a old
Land Cruiser like a Toyota fj40 you know
when those ones yeah she'd be like an
archaeologist or some [ __ ] right yeah
she had a [ __ ] pickaxe well that's
what she was in Avatar right in what is
this oh that's alien and that that's -
is that a record what is that so it's a
kid kid hang on to her bro oh my bad
that was alien alien - is not my
favorite because it's like wait a minute
why is it so easy to kill them all of a
sudden so easy to kill them because
there's so many of them like alien one
that [ __ ] thing was like it was
thinking yes it was it was ahead of you
every step of the way
alien - they just became like clumsy and
bumbling and you shoot them and there's
another one around the corner shoot that
one - it's like okay did I remember uh
arachnophobia had me shook remember that
one when those spiders gotten that
duplex bro that [ __ ] shook me to the
core do you see this one is like way
deep into the future
like the first one was in the 70s mm-hmm
and they're still doing them now
that's what's craziest - ready to bang
out new alien movies now they're
predator coming out they'd have a new
predator coming out they do hilarious
mm-hmm
why not make some money yeah let's do
that kind of stuffs fun it's probably
fun
I can't believe Brennan shibez Italian
would you say was British English yeah
yeah they came from Africa through engi
2,000 years ago his people did oh I'm
over time recently white yeah that's why
they call him big brown oh really no I
just made all that I thought he seemed
like he seemed pretty white to me when I
see right yeah a giant white dude yeah
he loved he always has he is the best
disposition doesn't break he just loves
to laughter yeah
you could think it's on he gets hated on
dudes get jealous do you get jaws but do
you think and also he says stupid shits
but but you think he feels that he feel
like is a special gift where you can
kind of especially if your buddy like
you can kind of joke with him and he
love like he just he knows that you love
him ya know he's a great guy he bros it
off he's got a great attitude like if
more people had his attitude with life's
problems
we'd have a happier world he knows how
to let things roll right off his back
it's big he's a smart guy man I always
like being around him yeah man he gets a
lot of hate online it's interesting yeah
I think it but I think it's guys that
are jealous cuz when I go on the road
like I just went to Bakersfield recently
which is can we just say it's like the
best people ever came out there's [ __ ]
amazing oh do I
I felt like I I thought like Hulk Hogan
bro people came out people were crying
someone sacrificed their cousin some guy
came out of the closet like oh wow they
wanted it all that happened at the show
you know people were giving me recipes
people were giving no I think man it
ain't that far now's an hour and a half
hour and 40 minutes how long does it
take to get the Bakersfield familiar two
hours two hours max it should be the new
capital bro it's not a bad spot and the
bleep are super-nice pretty diverse I I
mean yeah it was cool man I really liked
it
although I did turn my sink on its Brown
[ __ ] was [ __ ] flying out of the sink
like what [ __ ] is this it was like
Bakersfield what the [ __ ] is going on
with your water man to Saint good
because you know they're high school the
mascot it's they're called the drillers
there's like a team name because they're
oil drillers do you know that that whole
area is where there will be blood that
no Louis Lewis movie I love that guy
that's an amazing movie - so good that
there will be blood is about that whole
area that's where there's apparently
look at that doesn't my water coming out
of my [ __ ] sink did you drink any oh
yeah dude
and the worst is you already brushed
your teeth that's a crazy part - I don't
know that happens because you don't know
it first
ooh it's funky definitely seems like a
malt but I think that I was staying at
our super old hotel like real old from
the 1800s they like redid it downtown
yeah what does it call it the Ace Hotel
the didn't say God Dre I didn't tell
people or stood because I didn't want to
be mean to the hotel the Padre hotel I
think is a whole place yes I think
that's it was nice hit a nice it was
nice in there it is nice resonator yeah
yeah but it's just they they got some
old ass pipes clean those pipes on yeah
something's going wrong yeah I was
staying there son yeah what if what if I
took a mouthful that drank it what he
died what if I was just [ __ ] all
over myself for the rest of the day and
I to cancel my shows oh how about that
he will be here yes it [ __ ] angry
rightly so this should be furious dude
do you think you will die one day or not
I'm not trying to make you think about
I'm pretty sure that's how the world
that's how the road goes yeah you're
born and then you die what do you think
I don't know me where Christ she doesn't
think you die yeah yeah I think I think
he's just drunk yeah that could be it -
yeah another shirt on do you have to put
a shirt on to decide if you're gonna die
or no he goes prove it we we have to
base this on what we know about people
now I know the people you used to be
alive and now they're not so what
happened to them
are they faking it you know like you
will you be sad if you die you think I
don't think I'll be dead bro yeah what
about you I'd be sad if you died oh
thank you I'd be sad if you died -
thanks man I would be do you worry about
the end of your life yeah I worry about
it in the sense it makes me really
wonder then what does my time mean what
does your time mean
like what's important to you in this
life right now I think probably being
just feeling more okay with myself
probably hmm and trying to have maybe
help other people being more okay with
yourself like what what bothers you
about yourself oh I just wish I just
felt more comfortable my own skin a lot
of times you know because I feel like I
would be able to be more effective as a
person if I could just they kind of get
a not toil in some of my own you know
the small self-worth issues a wound like
lack of confidence at times you know I
wish I could trust my instincts and I
wish my instincts were like better
calibrated so that I knew when I was
what if I was doing like okay and good
stuff and my insides like told me you're
being ok you don't have to worry you
know there's a lot of things going on
there right one of them the big one is
almost always from your childhood
almost feelings of lack of Worth and
self-worth come from that feeling as
you're developing as you're growing up
yeah you feel like you're not loved are
you're not appreciated or you're you're
criticized too much you feel like you're
a loser and really because like
psychologically to be very hard to shake
and even as people get older sometimes
they still they still cling to this
thought that they're they're a piece of
[ __ ] because they're a piece of [ __ ] in
someone's eyes when they were 8 yeah
there were 10 that's a real problem with
people man
and that's one of the reasons why when
someone gets bullied when they're young
it can be so devastating because it's
happening when you're in high school or
junior high school and it becomes a
defining moment for you yeah yeah it's -
I was scared as one kid really also
about this one kid one of the reasons
why I got into wrestling this kid like
we had this confrontation in a locker
room mm-hmm
and I didn't think we were gonna fight
like I was just totally bluffing I don't
know what what I said or what he said I
don't remember but I do remember him
getting me in a headlock throwing me on
the ground and then leaning like he was
gonna punch me in the face but deciding
not to and I didn't know what to do
I had no know martial arts skills no
nothing
right I have I'd never wrestled anybody
before I didn't know anything so there's
nothing in you that is like any reaction
panicked and no idea what to do and I
think on a thought [ __ ] I didn't think
he was gonna do that and now here I am
on my back I'm trapped like god dammit I
gotta learn how to wrestle I gotta learn
some martial arts or something so then I
started taking karate and then I started
taking wrestling like right after that
but I avoided that kid every time I saw
him I see him on the other side of
school I'd like see you through the
breezeway and I'm always knew where he
was I wanna see that guy that threw me
on the ground and could have punched me
in the face it was almost like more
humiliating that he could have punched
me in the face but he didn't but that
bullying and that guy doing that to me
that fear of like being just helpless
mm-hmm made me get into martial arts I
was like [ __ ] this like I gotta figure
out how to fight I don't want this to
happen to me so they said that said you
said there's the benefit mean if it was
a lucky situation to like he didn't beat
me up it could have been way worse it
was not that big a deal it's an easy
school to go do like my school wasn't
hard even though there was some
criminals that were in that school like
some kids that get shipped into there
was some bad kids and one of them got
charged with murder like right after
graduating whoa our friend Kevin we knew
this dude he killed somebody more like
whoa yeah everybody was like whoa that
guy killed somebody I think he was one
year older than me yeah he murdered
somebody like right after high school
yeah there's a kid we knew he was on the
football team
we like knew him and do you never think
he would murder somebody he was a tough
guy
yeah a scary guy for sure like a
powerhouse of a person like a tank um I
didn't know him well though but I you
know I'd say hi to him but it's one of
those things where when something like
that happens to you and for me again it
was a very minor yes I was just scared
of this guy and I he didn't do anything
to me horrible just threw me on the
ground so I'd like you to beat your
brains I mean if someone could hold you
down I thought I could do it could've
beat my face and I wouldn't been able to
do [ __ ] are you grateful in a weird way
that he didn't they're not great yeah
look I'm sure for sure it was enough he
just let me know I was you know I don't
know what I said I'm it I said something
stupid he might have said something
stupid and wanted me to back down and I
didn't say he just grabbed me
threw me on the ground but the fact that
he that he did it and could do it led me
to make one of the biggest decisions of
my whole life is getting involved in
martial arts
didn't want that feeling anymore if like
if someone talked like gives me a hard
time I want to be the one who can decide
whether or not this gets violent or who
gets hurt I don't want to leave that
into some stranger's hands who might be
a [ __ ] psychopath yeah if it's in my
hands no one's getting hurt we're gonna
be finally there's a video of Matt Serra
from yesterday Matt Serra there was a
drunken altercation with some [ __ ]
dude in a food court Matt Serra who is a
Brazilian jiu-jitsu black belt at one
point in time when he was competing he's
one of the best Brazilian jiu-jitsu
artists in the world then on top of that
he fought in MMA
knocked out Georges st. Pierre won the
welterweight title and he's got some
dude on the ground and he's just saying
calm down calm down the guy's like I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up I'm gonna [ __ ] but
it's hilarious to watch like look at
this look at play it good and play the
volume he's like I'm gonna break your
[ __ ] face there get he's holding his
wrists I love how he has a shirt on the
guy's face he's like calm down calm down
it's like he's putting a crying baby to
sleep and so the security guard comes
over and says let him go he goes okay
you're gonna control them
[Music]
are you gonna control the noises are you
gonna control oh yeah are you ready to
control him like he's not he's standing
up and he's fat and let me tell you
something Matt Serra's one of the nicest
[ __ ] guys on the planet Earth if he
has to do this to you in a restaurant
he's a restaurant he's got full mount on
you you [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up dude but see you're way
way better off with Matt Serra in that
position then that drunk dude on some
guy who doesn't know how to fight it
could be that - that drunk dude could
just be a real mean violent person who
wants to beat someone up if he gets them
down so if there's guys like you know
who aren't into that kind of so you
found getting into martial arts are
really kind of led you in like a way
where you felt more confident in case
things got into an uncomfortable
situation that you would be okay yeah
well look you're always you're always
gonna be nervous in life when
something's important whether it's going
on stage or something difficult in life
you know difficult things make you
nervous it's like there's an
anticipation there's an understanding of
the difficulty of something you're about
to pursue and whether or not you're
gonna fall short or whether or not
you're gonna succeed that [ __ ] makes
people nervous but the physical
confrontation nervousness is a bad one
that's it that's not like that is a
paralyzing fear yeah no you need to feel
of being hurt and you can't do anything
about that devastates people that puts
them in a deep deep depression yeah so
it's really important to look I think I
think every young man should learn how
to fight I think there would be way less
fights because of it and I don't think
you have to be a mean person to learn
martial arts I think it's a skill and I
think you learn it and then once you
start getting good at it it started
actually starts actually becoming fun
and the people who you practice it with
you you become close with yeah you don't
you don't hate the people that you're
practicing fighting with they become
some of your closest friends yeah and I
think it's just a big it's a giant
confidence boost to know that you can do
something difficult and get better at it
that's I think just that alone it has
massive benefits for people yeah you
know I can sense them and I'm we were
watching a video a couple years ago
actually
like getting a belt or something they
gave you a some dojo or I'm not sure the
correct terminology was it might have
been a bj you probably watching when I
got my black belt yeah maybe that was it
but anyway it yeah like all there was a
lot of guys around it just and I know
that Koko does it Joey does it loves it
you look why don't you do it you're a
strapping man I talked to Eddie drama
about going to do it one - do it so he
said uh he said yeah come he said come
down one day and he'll you know get me
you know like one of the beginners
classes I think I didn't do it
[ __ ] yeah you make me feel a little bit
more yeah like you said sometimes are
just uh I don't know some and especially
like if people get bullied and then they
don't have like a brother or they don't
have a friend or they don't even have
somebody to go like talk to they'll be
like oh man and then their buddy be like
oh it's okay you know like that see
that's that can mate you know then that
person gets stuck inside themselves just
feeling like you know like they're not
gonna be okay you know
no it's terrifying and then everywhere
you go you're you're just scared of
running into this guy yeah it's very
very bad you know that's get into the
venomous do it it's a [ __ ] natural
animal inclination to pick on the weak
you know only humans realize it and stop
it and actually tell people not to do it
and understand the effect that it has on
the people that do it but every animal
does it dogs do it chickens do it
chickens have a pecking order they [ __ ]
one chicken and then they all decide I
let's [ __ ] with this [ __ ] and they all
attack her for no reason it's weird man
and you seen it everybody seen dogs do
it one dog will blow up and the other
dog the other dog will cower and then
they decide the pecking order I mean and
then that dog will always go near that
dog and [ __ ] with them and growl at him
maybe bite his ear or something like
that yeah it's a weird thing that
animals figured out how to make sure
that the only ones that get to breed are
the ones that are confident and powerful
and can overcome problems okay and one
of the problems is other mating they're
viable males that want to mate with the
women that you want to mate with like
with this [ __ ] giraffe they wound up
killing those three other giraffes this
guy just was like [ __ ] these [ __ ]
coming up I'm gonna smash my head into
these giraffes to stop them you ain't
[ __ ] these girls when you get older
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and
is just a natural inclination that
animals have to find the weak and force
it out and we don't have it well we do
we did have it fortunately we have it
less now I said we realized because of
communication right we realized that
there's devastating effects nest then we
have loving and caring communities we
have compassion that you shouldn't do
that right there's an inclination that
people have to pick on the weak and
attack the weak it's very it's very
disturbing but it's also very logical in
terms of like biology right we're trying
to make it difficult for males to breed
it's not like we have very few people
and we're trying to make as many people
as we get no no it's like the the high
status males and the dominant males are
competing against these other males in
order to be able to breed with you know
whatever yeah lizards or [ __ ] wolves
or any any and any species yeah high
status male wolf is the one who gets to
breed with the the choice females and
this is how they're carrying their genes
on it happens in deer it happens in elk
it happens in all these different
animals it's and they fight I mean the
reason why these these antlers on this
an elk yeah those are for fighting
that's all they're for they actually
lose those [ __ ] things after they're
done breeding really they fall off and
they grow back again the next year that
it's the fastest body-part growth known
to man is elk antler's and that look I
mean when you look at those it looks
like it would take 70 years to grow yep
they grow those [ __ ] in a
couple of months Wow and then it'll grow
bigger next year up until a point
sometime around like age nine or ten
sometimes they taper off and they start
to decline as they get older yeah
they're their antlers actually become
smaller and smaller but for the most
part as the that's one of the reasons
why people want to shoot a big male is
cuz that male like with big antlers that
male spread his genetics for many many
years so his genes are long passed on
he's probably bred with dozens of
females oh I see so if it has if it
obviously been alive a long time and it
has that family treatise hanging out of
the front of its head exactly then you
know okay this thing is already it's
already prospered yeah and the idea also
is that to only shoot those males
those those high-status big males it's
actually better for the population
because then the younger males get a
chance to become older mm-hmm because
they'll kill him
they killed young males if a young male
gets [ __ ] frisky and he thinks he's a
badass the big old bull will [ __ ] them
up and one of the ways they [ __ ] them up
is their antlers are longer so they can
get the young one when the young one
can't get him
nothing misguided and kind of evil like
you're your weapons are dictated by your
age it's really weird right and you're
strengthened like how vite how much
vitality you have that's what grows your
antlers out in that I mean that's
fascinating yeah that's how it all that
it's all put together like that it is
[ __ ] up and they bully the [ __ ] out of
those young bulls they chase him away
you get no [ __ ] those those young bulls
are they're calm satellite Bulls they're
so horny are they just hanging on the
outside we're gonna blues that's like
they're susceptible to hunters because
hunters will like make a cow calling
yeah okay what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and then they get shot yeah it's how
they get that's one of the things about
elk hunting that's so interesting is
that you call them in actually make
sounds to try to bring them towards you
so they think they're gonna get some
[ __ ] or they think there's a fight
that's the other thing you do you make a
bugle they have these horns you blow
yeah these bugles and then the elk will
go what you want some of this [ __ ] and
he'll come around the corner look for ya
looking for another elk to [ __ ] up and
then then shoot them would you ever get
in like a suit or anything like that and
do it no that pretend to be an elk yeah
like sneak up on them they have actual
elk decoys that they use that they
actually put on the front of the bow so
like say if you were shooting your bow
right you got your bow here extending in
front of your bow is like a like an L it
looks like like like a female elk it's
like a decoy and you're actually
shooting through her at the elk oh okay
it's like a decoy that you put on in
front of your bow you're drawing back
your bow we got something here like
rocket pussy's like a weapon in it elk
blow that toy what is this that is weak
so popped up when I techno
it's a new product was it's a adjustable
fit ball cap so what is that mask
it's that LK that's a good way to get
shot by a dude it's a good put one of
those on a water ops oh so that's what
that is what it is it's like an elk head
you know who has one of those John
Dudley has something like that guys like
years he wears you tricking or treating
him looking at the filter that's it you
look like I don't think their vision is
very good oh I say I think their vision
is have you ever watched any of them
have sex or they don't yeah yeah I saw
one of them I saw male elk [ __ ] a female
it was crazy
really is it pretty cool or mashed it he
smashed it so hard she went flying
forward what she got tackled went down
to her front knees he just climbed on
top and he's a one-pump chump boom he
just slammed into it could you tell he
felt good after eating like whatever
Sally's screaming when they're [ __ ]
and when they were in in heat and
they're eating in the rut they call it
it's amazing to watch I mean this is
something they only do once a year so
for 11 months out of the year they're
cool with each other
they're all just hanging out together
and one month out of the year it's chaos
just fighting to the death with other
males and smashing into it and then
every girl they get a chance they bang
it out and then when it's over it's over
and then this is a cycle of life and
then in the spring the new calves are
born and then you know they they grow up
and then a year later they're hanging
around and the the pack and then they
get older is that they get older to
challenge the old bull for dominance and
chases them away and yeah it's it's a
fascinating sort of ecosystem when you
want and then you know there's always
wolves and there's always bears and
those all these things are trying to eat
them and mountain lions are killing them
it's amazing that's wild man it's wow
that's good that's neat that you're so
in tune with all of that stuff man that
you you know you're into this world that
sounds like a lot of fun you know well
it's really interesting even if I never
ever hunted again I would still be
fascinated by wildlife yeah it is just
it's one of the more interesting things
about being alive there's
there's these other things that are
alive too and they're nothing like us
yeah they are nothing like us without
outliers really oh for sure for sure but
we're the ones who are separated from
them so completely that if we see one
it's like a bird that's sitting on a
flagpole yeah it's you know it's [ __ ]
coyote in your neighborhood well what's
he doing here you know like the or a dog
which is like our friend you know dog
I don't even count them as animals I
know they're animals but they're our
friends it's like when you have dogs
either they're dependent upon us for
food they're part of the family it's a
totally different deal than like a pet
wolf or a pet bear or some [ __ ] there's
an episode where somebody's dog plays
family feud with them no I'm saying so
that's uh yeah you what other animals
gonna do that
I saw dude online who talked is he
trained his dog to get him a beer and he
put a tighter towel to the door or the
refrigerator
you'd say go get me a beer and the dog
would go there she would grab ahold of
towel pull on it it would open up the
door to the fridge she would reach in
grab a can of beer run over hand the can
of beer to him he'd say good now go
close the door and she would go close
the door she would go grab that towel
and use it to shut that door I was like
that is insane
that is a super trained animal man
mm-hmm
yeah I never had a dog I know we were
talking last night at the comic store
about your dog and you you know you guys
always seem to be super happy like when
y'all go running and everything they're
talking about school you ever have any
pets no I never had any pets never
growing up uh-uh
responsibility they had scary dogs I'd
like they had loose dogs and her
neighborhoods like Rottweilers Doberman
you know so it was like it wasn't nobody
had a pet like everybody had like there
were two dogs they were like [ __ ] you
know you'd see him [ __ ] and sometimes
like attack so it's kind of exciting but
it wasn't like and then a lot of animals
got hit by my house by this highway by
trucks and so we'd go bury the animals
sometimes oh really yeah so we go get
the animal you know pull them right off
this little highway and bury them but um
but yeah I never had a pet but I would
like to have one if I can get a home one
time you know a home and like a wife and
stuff and I think I would like to have
an animal you know they're fun man B got
a
really know what you're getting into if
you go out of town you're gonna need
somebody to watch it feed it and take
care of it you know you gotta get that
you gotta make sure you have a big
enough yard or your dog can get some
exercise yeah they're gonna [ __ ] all
over the place you're gonna have to
learn how you pick that up you gonna
have to pick that [ __ ] up yeah you know
can you teach them to [ __ ] in like a
hole or something nope nope they [ __ ]
wherever they go outside they just find
a spot and say this is a good spot to
[ __ ] and they just drop logs yeah and
then you got logs all over your lawn
yeah and if you go two days without
cleaning those logs you got eight logs I
have three dogs
so a dogs makes mucho logs then if I
don't clean it up off that [ __ ] smell
going to be out in the yard like a
really harsh it's mouse and you got to
get the scraper little scraper and
scrape the logs and then I have a place
I'd dump them into yeah scooping up [ __ ]
imagine if your grandma just [ __ ] all
over your on just go out go out in the
lawn just she shits in the yard shits on
the lawn like clean up her [ __ ] yeah I
love her but god I hate cleaning her
[ __ ] yeah I would hate cleaning up
probably human [ __ ] for some reason but
I remember the dog [ __ ] well when I was
a kid they had to blend our neighborhood
named Mario right and he uh and he was
dude he ended up dying actually did some
pills and drove into an embankment but
he when I was young he would [ __ ] in his
yard make me bury it and that's how
that's how I was allowed to be friends
with him well how did he make you bury
it he just asked me to do it and I was
afraid not to do it I said yo dude
you're gonna believe this but I took a
[ __ ] and it's out my I can't even bury
it because I'll throw up hey do me a
favor and go bury it yeah he was he did
he was dark man he had a he had a real
dark vision and he would uh he would I
mean he probably honestly dude he
probably [ __ ] two hundred three hundred
times and I buried it I swear to God I
swear to God I swear to God dude and he
um how'd you not run out of places to
make new holes do you think you ever dug
up old [ __ ]
to put a new [ __ ] oh yeah I wouldn't be
surprised man hey we basically had like
they'll only set up I had not even have
a strong system the only setup had was
like a one of this plastic uh you know
beach Oh setup dude I was seven so wait
a minute the seven year old was doing
this how old was he he was eight or nine
Oh
he's tricking you but yeah an older he
was older and two years when you're
seven is a long stretch now when you're
32
yeah 32 34 doesn't mean [ __ ] whatever
dude put seven and nine that's a big
stretch yeah you go [ __ ] at your house
buddy that's what I tell people now
[Laughter]
- what he would what was the firmer the
first there's no way you really remember
I remember instead I don't remember what
he said but I remember how did it happen
how did it happen we find yourself with
a plastic shovel and another person [ __ ]
going damn how did it come to this
well it came to it because he I know my
brother probably wasn't around and I
wanted somebody to play with and he was
older so I was hanging out and he was
deviant man how so he just had a little
bit of like like he was kind of
slithering you know what I'm talking
about my mom he knew how to manipulate
you
yeah he was obviously buried his [ __ ]
200 plus times like there wasn't he had
the same color in the outside of his eye
on the inside of his I took him out
demon yeah like a light dealer Diablo
yeah like a el Diablo but also who was
in elementary school ah interesting
um but he so when you first found
yourself do you remember them the
feeling that you first found when you
were digging a hole for a dude's [ __ ]
like just thinking what am i how long
can I do this what if he keeps asking
how do I stop this how'd you wind up
stopping that's maybe a better question
you know what I don't remember how it
kind of you know pant you know how you
do off yeah peterhof how it kind of
tapered off his parents ever like hey
you ever [ __ ] in the house how come we
don't have any missing toilet paper well
did you know that's what I think it was
I think he was lazy or you know he's I'm
serious and he shout outside behind his
slide they had a slide in his yard kiss
a do you know a little bit of money and
he shout outside behind the slide this
is a great word to buy and it was silty
kind of soil and sand and I remember
going over then I still remember
I remember the shade of it honestly
would it look like I would say like a
taupe but a little bit a little more
Brown in it you can always find coyote
[ __ ] because it has like little berries
in it a lot of times coyotes eat all
kinds of things yeah yeah eat some
berries sometimes I'll see these logs
like these little red berries in and I'm
like oh that's coyote [ __ ] mmm it's
always a dark brown to their [ __ ] super
consistent it's weird gooses have fancy
[ __ ] sometimes aciem you mean disgusting
yeah I never liked it but it seems
creatures yeah
and that's a bait-and-switch by mother
nature because if you see a goose you
think oh this is fun this can be
exciting another me and then they'll
[ __ ] choke out an infant at a park I
mean gooses are violent they're violent
it's really violent Nate they they fight
impacts do they have impacts yeah they
do
I have a friend had a house on a lake
and they had a wire all around the lake
I was like what's the wire for Doug is
to keep the goose from going into the
water they don't want him waddling into
the water the other thing I was like is
that electric like what kind of face is
that I'm not sure if a thing I'm not
sure of its electric might give him a
little shock but the idea was to try to
keep the because they [ __ ] all over
their lawn the shits in here where
they're at a pond in their yard
yeah there looks like the ultimate like
that kid marry a hitter site that came
marry oh but a bird I'm balling on you
and you have a pond in your yard like
you want to go fishing yeah take five
steps out of my backyard you know you
know that's like the ultimate but I
don't think that's it I don't think if
you have a natural Hill in your yard
kind of I don't think that's that
expensive to get water put in and to get
a pump put in I don't think it to that
drastic man I would think that would be
a nightmare but you got to make sure it
doesn't leak like you Adam
like what's gonna keep the water there
yeah it takes a special kind of bottom
like when you go to a natural lake like
that's that water's pulled up there for
a reason like that's an unusual ground
you got to realize if you're looking at
natural existence of the lake the waters
decide to stay there
whereas the same amount of water has
probably landed everywhere but it's
decided to stay there so what the hell's
different between that ground and all
the other ground around it so when you
want to make a pond you just can't make
a pond everywhere there's a reason why
there's not a pond there it's that's not
the kind of ground for a pond right so
they'd have to put a liner in oh you got
a tame mother it's like taming mother
nature almost yeah you have to do
something you can't just pour water in
there and you got to do something and
one of the things that they do in a lot
of places they use this really thick koi
pond liner it's basically a plastic
liner so you got a bullshit-ass fake
pawn it's way you got that's gonna look
shitty got a above-ground pool yeah you
know basically the above-ground pool of
ponds it's not even organized you know
well once they get the liner in place
then they put surface levels of dirt and
rocks and stuff over the liner so it
looks like a regular pond but the thing
is though what's holding the water in
place in some places they they'll use
those koi pond you ever see you know
what a koi pond yeah yeah it's big
beautiful got a restaurant yeah they
have very thick liner that they use for
the base of that [ __ ] use that stuff on
float tanks to flotation tanks we've
floated them oh no I mean yeah her you
talked about before well that the liner
of those things is the same thing it's
koi pond like a liner it's like a real
thick durable tough plastic does he feel
like you're alive when you're in the
tank yeah it feels like you're relaxing
you know it's a good feeling feels good
on your body just alleviates tension but
it also feels like you're in this like
meditative state you relax and you think
about things better there mmm you get a
good good thought of you know what how
to look at things from an outside
looking in perspective yeah you get a
chance to be away from your body really
because you're not thinking about your
body just floating oh I like that
you're not feeling your body at all the
water is the same temperature as your
skin so it you don't you can't even tell
where the water is and where the where
your body is oh I like that yeah I just
feel like you're flying through the air
it's all dark and you don't see anything
you don't hear anything cuz your ears
are underwater does it feel dead do you
feel like you might be dead or not no
definitely not I like that you worry
about the feeling of dead I'm just
worried about how does the fizzing like
did
your brains keep going you know or
whatever it is it keeps us going in art
like it when you die yeah like there's
our consciousness does it just leave out
of this shell and then we're just part
of this straight up [ __ ] I think part
of the thing is when we're thinking
about consciousness we're thinking about
language so we're thinking about the way
we talk and think about a feeling yeah
because I think what we think of as
consciousness when I think of it when my
own limited mind when I think of
consciousness I think of consciousness
is me using language to interpret how I
feel about different things I have
there's a language attached to it I
think if something happens when you die
and your soul goes to another place
let's say a soul is a real thing or
consciousness is a real thing I bet it
goes there with no language and I bet
that's it's real similar I bet to what
it feels like when you're really
tripping okay when you're on some heavy
psychedelics and you just melt into the
universe and you you sort of cease to
exist on some of them like five Meo DMT
you've ever been on that yeah Wow
you melt into the center of the universe
you feel like you don't exist anymore
I bet death and they that feels like
you're dying too that's that's it yeah
that's a scary one five Meo DMT is a
universally disturbing one a lot of
people have a problem with that one
because it really does feel like you're
dying can senior citizens do it or not
I think they can yeah I think the only
problem would be if you had a heart
attack freaked out
I think it's toxic because your body
makes it your body knows what to do with
it too you know your body knows how to
bringing you back down to sobriety
levels in like 15-20 minutes do you know
when you're going into those kind of
when you're ill and some of that do you
get a feeling that if you're a good or
bad person did you get do you get like
an aunt that like well I get a feeling
if there's things that are bothering you
about your behavior you know if you're
if you have something that's that's
haunting you and maybe with a lot of
people it really comes down to life
choices not just in terms of like their
behavior but even like what they're
doing with for a living and how they're
living their life and sometimes those
experiences these psychedelic
experiences can highlight these things
that are bothering you but that you're
suppressed
and then you realize like oh this
suppressing of these feelings and
thoughts is actually making me lash out
in these other ways
I've got shitty behavior and I'm
aggressive in this way because and it's
really because of this Wow it's really
because of and then you might you might
also come to realization it's about
something that happened you were a child
or it's about feeling unprotected or
unloved as a child and it's just you
never develop properly so you never felt
totally secure so you want to do
something to make you feel secure
whether it's drinking or something and
then you'll see that in a psychedelic
experience you'll be able to like see
the root of it better oh wow
for a lot of people its cessation of
smoking comes from that feeling like oh
this is I'm killing myself because I
hate myself like I'm literally poisoning
myself like how could I not see this and
then through having a mushroom
experience they've just completely quit
really so yeah it's a real common one
real common one there's a lot of other
stuff that I haven't done that that also
like ibogaine is a big one for getting
people off drugs it's a huge yeah I
heard about that yeah that's a big one
that has an amazing success rate but
it's supposed to be really brutal and as
far as like how you feel like like it
runs you through the ring or
psychologically uh-huh but when you get
through it it's worth it
but it's 24 hours [ __ ] and who do you
have to go with by yourself there's a
lot of clinics that do it particularly
in Mexico a lot of people go down to
Mexico and go these clinics in their
24-hour clinics of this ibogaine
experience JRE field trip but hey man if
you have a son
and if you like Joe my son's hooked on
oxy I don't know what to do I would a
hundred percent recommend you do that
really yeah because I know so many
people that have done it and it's helped
them it rewires the way your brain
connects to addiction it's really fast
it's a fascinating drug Hamilton Morris
who is the host of vices Hamilton's
pharmacopoeia it's a essentially a show
that's all just about drugs hmm
he was talking about last week about how
fascinating it is and in low doses it
actually is like a nootropic it actually
enhances your consciousness and low
doses make
you smarter yeah yeah you know I want to
get into some of that kind of stuff but
I mean I you know so right now I don't
party or anything like that so I
struggle with that it's like mana you
know because I don't you know it's tough
because I do want to be able to be do
things that are beneficial for myself
and things that I didn't have a problem
with but it's all just hard to kind of
balance yeah you want to stay sober yeah
yeah well you know sobriety is a
worthwhile goal and if you can go from
being a person who's doing a lot of
drugs and ruining their life the person
who's like yourself that's on a great
path and you're sober and you're
disciplined you wouldn't want to break
that right you don't want to have that
bad feeling but there's ways you can
achieve certain psychedelic states
without any drugs yeah one of the big
ones is yoga and meditation those are
two big ones yeah I mean I don't do the
kind of yoga that gives you a
psychedelic experience I think mostly
that's Kundalini Yoga but the kind of
yoga that I do that become hot yoga [ __ ]
it's just this this what it does to your
body and chills you out afterwards I
think it has a pretty profound effect on
the way the world the way you experience
the world after the classes is that I
think that's something that people don't
take into consideration like one way in
which you can change the world around
you is to change how you interface with
the world and how you experience the
world
how are you viewing it what is your
what's your behavior flavored by is your
behavior motivated by frustration and
and weirdness and insecurity and anger
or is your behavior motivated by love
and confidence and Happiness and are you
like are you quenched physically do you
feel good physically yeah and if you do
and if you've like experienced like a
strong yoga class and then you run into
someone you might be more relaxed more
compassionate more easily and that
that'll change the way that person
thinks about you that'll change your
interaction with them in the future that
might change your whole life yeah and if
you continue to act that way and you
continue to look at world through the
eyes of this this very particular
discipline it's really good for your
body it really can change people yeah
change a lot
people it's like there's a definite
butterfly effect from that yeah so if
you want to just do something for you
I'm just meditating man learn how to
meditate yeah I just got a new
meditation chair actually yesterday so I
might have to start giving me be getting
into it too why not man I mean if you
were interested in doing drugs right why
not just be interested in doing
something that you know you could
definitely do and it's not gonna [ __ ]
you up and it's only gonna help you yeah
so yeah when you were when you were
partying what was your thing just doing
cocaine by myself at the house really
cocaine yeah it's all cocaine yeah what
about booze the booze bother you no I
just couldn't have a drink because I'd
be afraid that I would buy I would buy a
coke
so if you got drunks then it would
loosen your inhibitions and you'd be
like where's the coke what's the [ __ ]
coke yeah dude and cocaine oh go back to
that vest story man so well here's what
happened so I you know I would get I
would do some cocaine a thousand put on
these different vests did you barn you I
don't know I spent too much on him but I
would probably say the priciest one I
had was probably about $210 nice AM yeah
and so I would get [ __ ] up and put
these vests on and put on sunglasses and
not let no like Buffalo Bill [ __ ] but at
least partying by myself you know and
one time I was making a smoothie you
know cuz I you know I have I got like a
new one what kind of blender it is but
it's pretty nice and I was making like a
nice smoothie and I'm [ __ ] coked up
I'm partying you know I'm living high on
the hog two vests on maybe right and I
thought I I thought I heard something
outside right which is kind of weird to
even think of when you have a blender
going right so I'll leave out of my
apartment to go in the hallway lock
myself out with the blender going coked
up out of my brain right I have to go to
my landlord dude right down the hall
tell him like hey man during the morning
I got locked out oh my god he must have
hated you oh the blender shorts out and
smoke happens the fire huh along starts
going off in the building right as I'm
at his door knocking right so now he's
pissed and he's like what's going on and
I didn't know what to say I told him
that I was throwing a late Christmas
party dude it was [ __ ] into January
how old were you at the time huh two and
a half years ago so he comes back to my
apartment my god man but that's it it
was fine
oh my god no that was fine
how long did you live there for I still
live there whoa
yeah we passed you know like I've caught
him doing some things how long you been
sober for two years in two weeks it'll
be two years what was the big thing were
you like I gotta get my [ __ ] together
you doubt was going on opium Jim when
hoping Jim Norton had a radio show it's
serious and it was actually on it's on
Ari's that show that he had this is not
happening and I ended up doing coke all
night driving a taxi I was in a taxi the
driver is dude Luigi got me an escort
I didn't want to escort we're doing
cocaine in like Harlem or something
north-holland the cab driver doing coke
and I just had I was taking a cab from a
party to my hotel and so we end up off
on this other excursion next you know
I'm driving the taxi he's in the back
with the hooker it's 5:30 in the morning
and I got to be on the radio station at
you know 6:30 or something so I get to
the radio and I can't even talk and uh
and Darryl strawberry's the other guest
right who's the baseball player who also
had drug problem but he's like 13 years
soberin so it was this weird moment
where like I thought I was kind of cool
but then here's a man who like I'd
always in my head maybe somewhere
thought oh that guy's like a coke head
within here he is eloquent put together
successful and Here I am I can't even
talk and I'm with two men that I admire
you know being Jim Norton just to be
honored to be on the show you know and
so I was like this is um I'm not making
choices like there's some there's some
unevenness here you know and so what did
you do after that two hundred twelve
step program join 12-step program yeah
and then so yeah so I've been in that
then it since then it's helped me out
you know
well I would definitely say don't do
coke yeah the problem with drugs is
they're all under the same blanket right
you know when someone says drugs you
think of everything you think of pills
you think of smoking it you think of
coke you think of pot you think of
mushrooms think of everything yeah but
obviously they're not all the same thing
you know it's weird to call them all
drugs yeah they affect you very
differently 100% I don't think if you
did mushrooms you would all of a sudden
be doing blow and you know yeah I don't
think so either in Luigi's cab again
right I don't think so either so but I
think I wouldn't want to be the guy that
told you do no I don't feel like you are
but you know I feel like it's something
that I think about sometimes and but you
know I don't know cuz I also do want to
have experiences where like I'm able to
get you know unique experiences out of
my out of my mind and think about other
stuff and like you know I do remember
times where mushrooms would just clear
my conscience it would be like someone
came up to the chalkboard where
everybody written all these math
problems and [ __ ] and somebody drawn
a dick and to somebody [ __ ] cutting
off somebody's head just stupid [ __ ]
right and just clean it all off and
you're like oh no I think so too is
relaxing mushrooms forgive you I'll give
you for your mistakes I mean this is one
of the reasons why like mushrooms and
Jesus are always kind of connected in
folklore and a lot of people's ideas
it's because they're both very forgiving
like here's the best Jesus story of
someone being forgiving
goddamn coughing lump it's the weed um
there was a guy named general butt naked
you ever heard of that guy real man yeah
he lived in Liberia and he's a famous
character in Liberia because of his
exploits when he was in in the middle of
war he would he would go and and fight
naked oh wow
and he was a cannibal he would kill
innocent children on the other side and
to eat pieces of their heart and they
believed that it would protect him in
battle and talks about it openly
after doing this he found Jesus he came
on him he is this him
did you have a look I didn't know either
so then he became he I mean he's killed
thousands of people
oh he's apparently in in war and then
according to what he said and then
afterwards became a preacher and talks
openly about the fact that he's like
killed innocent children and eaten
pieces of their heart but people forgive
him because he's a preacher
so his love of Jesus is so complete that
people forgive him to the point where
they forgive the fact that he ate kids
Wow imagine how was if he was your it
was your kid that this guy ate then you
see him out preaching now I'll be pissed
Oh bro you ain't my kid yeah his heart
[ __ ] that was a different time
yeah I was a different man yeah it's
crazy the the four travelers guy I feel
it's called the Vice Travel Guide to
Liberia it is a really really
eye-opening sort of a view into what
Liberia is like night Liberia is a
really really poor dangerous part of
Africa that was originally when slaves
left America when they were set free
they went back to Liberia and that's
where they settled [ __ ] yeah
dude I Africa's always [ __ ] up huh
yeah that sucks man yeah that's why I'm
all these wild animal stories from
Africa it's like there's another one
that was kind of interesting these
poachers got eaten by a lion they tried
to get a hold of a rhino they were
trying to steal this kill this Rhino and
cut its horns off they try to sell him
and he just got eaten that's crazy dude
dude that's the way to go if you could
get an animal organ put into your body
would you do it will be the benefit
would you get I'd do something nothing
like a hyena but I already have the butt
of a Down syndrome boy so I don't know
what I would get man I would probably
get just something I'd start off with
something small probably look you know a
wrist or something more like a pinky
nail once there's a bit splicing genes
man
then we're gonna be able to do with
people you're gonna be like they got
Tigard oh it's a guy on a Thundercat
remember you gonna be like Thundercat
who's but I don't remember that guy with
the red mean he was like never tried
that I know it's definitely illegal but
you think there's a scientist yes right
I met a guy why some people with animals
fear yeah but wasn't it something we're
trying Stalin was trying to do that with
chimpanzees yeah he's trying to make
some sort of a chimp human hybrid yeah I
could see it man I've met some
[ __ ] dude some [ __ ]
yeah well I think they're gonna be able
to do something like that soon can you
appreciate in that you [ __ ] or
talking to somebody and then they just
get into a bird bath
okay this is that Humanzee thing
scientists claim us lab engineer to
Manzi human chimp hybrid 100 years ago
scientist that is this is a really
recent article huh this isn't science
alert oh this is the Sun super sketchy
right yeah
that Humanzee was real weird though that
thing walked upright a lot yeah and they
wore a suit what is that that's big
that's Stalin's Humanzee experiment but
that one picture is
real that one that one the one next to
the one you're at that one that's real
that's what it really looked like mm
thing walked around with shorts on yeah
the side of his quads son that
[ __ ] will tear you apart yeah
the thing I think it got very close to
the woman to which became an issue look
at that who is that
that's the Humanzee Martin's friend yeah
look he's doing coke with what does that
[ __ ] is that they got from narcosis in
the background stop look at that
language that's what I'm talking about
look at the writing tell me that [ __ ]
doesn't look alien like that's from some
spaceship like what language is that
I don't know I'm ready for it all
language the Japanese yeah that looks
like it should be on yeah don't don't go
back there we go
that language looks it does look like
like it's from space like if you saw
that on if you didn't know anything
about Asian languages you saw that on a
spaceship people like oh do you think
Japanese people could be from space and
not know that they are the people that
are really into nonsense like the
zecharia sitchin do you know about all
that [ __ ] there's people that believe
that there is a planet that's out far
outside of Pluto that comes it's a no on
an elliptical orbit and it comes near
earth every like three thousand years or
something I forget the exact number but
it's called Nibiru and on Nibiru there
are these people called the Anunnaki and
what they are is an alien race mmm and
that this alien race engineered us and
they took they took these old monkeys
like ancient hominids and then they
added their DNA to him and created a
human being this is the idea and then
there's this guy Zecharia Sitchin wrote
all these books on this stuff and
there's a lot of people who think he's
full [ __ ] but it's interesting it's fun
it's fun too it's fun to speculate you
know but the idea was that different
groups of people got different
level of alien hmm yeah I could yeah
well look sometimes I'm talking to
somebody I'm like I don't think this
dude is like a full person you know like
who who do we know don't tell em mm I
don't know if it's anybody that we know
um I mean Josh Martin networks this
house takes me for a ride but I don't
imagine if there was one just living
amongst us oh the whole time we just get
our chain yanked oh I bet I'm sure
there's some chick out there that's
[ __ ] an alien I think when I really
think about it I think that that would
be the first in breeding would be a
chick would let an alien [ __ ] it would
be a dude who [ __ ] an alien girl oh no
I think now these days there's I could
see some women [ __ ] some aliens well
isn't that some of the folklore though
some of the stories of male alien
abduction are like female aliens that
seduce them yeah that's how they get
your loads bro dude off species I've
been give him rides up for free sign
Natasha
Hendricks right is that her last name
and Strich Hendricks how do you say it
and Strich Henstridge so they said how
many loads can your body make you she
was on fear factor she's very nice she's
a very nice person
oh really you met her yeah she did an
episode of fear factor hottest [ __ ] Wow
Forest Whitaker was in that movie oh I
love Horace Whitaker damn Ghost Dog I'll
listen the hustler and he's in no hassle
King of Scotland he was in the color of
money not the hustler you know a movie I
like is um that movie where they escaped
from the mental health facility and
Michael Keaton's in it and it's like
four dudes and they go to a baseball
game you remember that movie no I think
it makes me think you probably wouldn't
be able to make that movie today yeah oh
yeah cuz a mental health facility or
some people be upset well there was
always dudes in movies that would play
there was guys that would play someone
who was mentally challenged
yeah that's a common thing dudes would
always do it didn't Sean Penn play
someone yeah I am saying challenged yeah
great Dustin Hoffman did he do it oh
that's right Wayne man Rosie O'Donnell
Oh Dustin Hoffman was probably the first
guy to play a super autistic man yeah
and he did great Rosie O'Donnell did it
too right I think so man that's the last
thing you want your enemies finding out
dude imagine the outtakes really start
laughing imagine the outtakes if you
start laughing you monster and nowadays
you have to have a real person with the
disease on the side of the stage so like
the consult yeah is that real yeah
that's crazy man come on
really I'm sure you think they're
letting you do that without having
somebody there to verify if it's legit
or not well how would someone verify
whether or not like like like it's
someone gonna come up and go that's
that's not how I do it I just that's
Rosie let me hear this let's try just
made that up why didn't you wait inside
riding the bus with my sister because
you can't see me in there I have your
address honestly
you just make things harder on yourself
buckle up for safety
whoa pretty good I wonder if you could
do that movie today you might not be
able to do it like 12 years ago yeah but
that's a different world man different
world man you can't even barely breathe
out there do you know it's tough right
but um dude I can't believe I'm going to
China in there you wonder what you can
do anything can you do anything as far
as like comedy material oh my dress no I
mean I'll just think of all the
different stuff they have animals are
treated differently there oh that's true
you know right but I think like you get
in trouble if you like Google certain
websites like they have a different
version oh yeah they're censored yeah
yeah I'm not gonna do anything drastic
like that crazy gets censor a billion
people how the hell'd you do that that's
pretty impressive dude I remember going
when I was a student we went to Cuba
when I was a student in college right
now I remember we went to a bookstore
and all the books just started at like a
certain year and that was it like there
was no you imagine that and it was like
in the nineteen whatever yeah when
Castro took over me like Che Guevara
this is going on today in China World
Cup kiss sparked social media debate on
sexual harassment in China oh wow
why uh he's a male reporter in these to
Russian fans gave him a kiss while he
was repairing and it's caused like a
reverse sexual harassment debate and
trans prion it's a big deal wow he looks
so what's a big deal that in China
someone like you're not allowed to show
public affection like that is that what
the big debate is here's a it came after
a bunch of female journalists have been
assaulted and so they started assaulting
the dude the other way around
oh um I'm gonna go out on a limb he's
gonna be okay he looks fine he looks
actually better in kissed on the cheek
by attractive women they're not hurting
them they can't rape him I think he's
gonna be okay let's watch homeboy get
mauled by these hot Russian broads here
it goes mwah kiss no nothing nothing
he's fine laughing okay we're done he's
laughing we're done stop this people are
[ __ ] crazy
the guy's laughing
he thought it was cute yeah why would
anybody make a deal out of that it's a
zero tolerance that girl literally had a
plastic red cup in her hand which is the
universal sign for being [ __ ] up in
public yeah if you got that plastic red
cup in your hand that chicks probably
lit she kissed that guy yeah he thought
it was cute they didn't move him around
or push him or assault him there's a
friendly gesture on the cheek that's
love I think why are we trying to shut
down people and join each other I don't
think we are anymore I think I think
things are actually think things are
getting in a lot better place and it's
just all in the media it seems like
they're not sometimes you know
wellthank that that seem like they're
not the fact that someone's making a big
deal out of that yeah that's true
you can't look you can't compare that to
a bunch of guys doing that to a girl
it's not the same it's not devastating
the guy's gonna be fine
it is different men and women are
different in that case that is a very
clear-cut case of no one got hurt yeah
did they interrupt his broadcast perhaps
did they ruin what he was trying to say
and this I don't know what he might had
a serious message and these Russian
broads come over and kiss him on the
cheek
maybe they [ __ ] up his little project
and what he's trying to accomplish yeah
but there's no crime there that's not a
crime it's not the same if that was a
bunch of dudes doing that to a pretty
girl yeah some gorilla looking [ __ ]
football player [ __ ] corn-fed Iowa
boys came over and kissed her who what
what are they doing remember when they
were trying to make it a big deal
because Katy Perry kissed some guy on
American Idol
yes remember that is like two months ago
yeah she kissed some boy had never
kissed a boy she kissed him she brought
him over and kissed him there was like
oh well what if worth Katy Perry wasn't
man what if that was a girl yeah she's
not stop she's Katy Perry and if that
guy is really complaining that Katy
Perry took her kiss I'm suing my kids
for something to growl at me dude no
one's gonna love you shut the [ __ ] up if
you can't appreciate Katy Perry kissing
you oh she's pretty too he's pretty and
more people will love that man because
Katy Perry kissed him Idol contestant
shuts down Katy Perry
oh he shut down the Katy Perry backlash
he kissed her to listen nothing wrong
with that look at him first of all
homies gay right is he
look at him he could be from Idaho who
shot him and he fell down that is not a
male mood that's not oh he could be okay
it might be he's avoiding that kiss
until he really did find the woman that
made him feel like he wanted to be
kissed and maybe she stole that from him
yeah see right here imagine of a 33 year
old male artist tricked a 19 year-old
female auditioner and do a kid's like
Katy Perry
well imagine that's a different thing
you [ __ ] how about you imagine that's a
whole different thing
yeah don't pretend that men and women
are the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
imagine a Volkswagon [ __ ] your stepmom
what are we doing not the same thing
everybody's okay that Chinese guy was
laughing man oh he probably jerked off
to the video at the house
Oh multiple times I'm going to [ __ ]
China to ask them something totally a
different fruit over there give it a
vacuum they have different fruit in
Brazil they have different fruit in
England you get some different fruit
[ __ ] man excited I'm excited I guess I'm
nervous but I'm also excited how many
shows you doing over there I'm doing
three shows but you know uh and I've you
know I I don't know about to promote you
know it's just a guy hit me up literally
over email and like oh wow it's a Nixie
no I'm going but next thing you know you
got a ballgame now tie it up at a
basement under a noodle shop somewhere
hey as long as I get to eat after Jesus
Christ are you looking forward to the
food no man no do you not like Chinese
food I mean I like about dude just
somebody told me that you can eat animal
dicks over there you can eat [ __ ]
elbow you were saying they could eat
human dicks I think you're just joking
around though right I don't know
honestly think about it
think what else you went over there and
they said we heard you on experience and
we have
a hockey rink and will prepared to put
on the lion fight are you prepared to
watch which if they brought to you to a
place and I said a dude's gonna fight
online with a sword
you could leave if you like yeah would
you stay I would stay yeah you'd have to
I would oh it to them if the man's
already gonna fight and I'm the only
imagine he comes out to fight a minute
no but is it the [ __ ] the stadium
well you would have to be able to trust
the people that are there that they're
gonna let this guy get ripped apart by a
lion in front of you and then get rid of
a body
yeah would you eat during it or would
you wait to eat after because the guy
depends on a hungry nose if they got my
weight yeah if the guy looks over in
your [ __ ] eating eating a hot dog
well this guy's getting mauled and he
looks something he makes eye contact
like say are you just saying that muster
on your face and [ __ ] our crowd the
teeth drinking a beer his head oh Jesus
bartender do that well yeah talk about
like that movie Gladiator with Russell
Crowe hmm what is that supposed to be
how long ago was that was it split based
that was like a thousand years ago yeah
I think it was like 980 I'm guessing or
2 mm mm-hmm
[ __ ] dude that ain't that long it's set
in Roman times so could we get back
there you think all around was exactly
yeah thank man says that's not that long
ago people were [ __ ] ad 100 180 180 ad
I was in Rome a couple years back and I
went to the Colosseum it's [ __ ]
amazing man it's crazy to be there just
to feel it and then most of its missing
mm-hmm like they stripped down a lot of
the stone and people stole things from
it and it's like it's all dilapidated
and falling apart but they wanted to
Louis they take you through the
catacombs and they sort of explain all
the different things but they had these
animals they'd gotten from Africa and
they had kept them in the but see that
hole in the ground that's really real
that's really how they did it man these
animals would come out
of a [ __ ] hole in the ground and you
see that first layer of people the first
seat the first row seats they had to put
up [ __ ] fences and [ __ ] because the
Tigers would leap through the air and
kill the people that are in the first
row stub people up those StubHub those
season pass holders imagine you get that
nice ticket and you fight your buddy you
get up to get a soda and you come back
and your buddies just in pieces dude
though just the fact that people did do
stuff like that we did that it's in us
do you know that that's what's crazy man
that's your show makes me think about
stuff like that like that there's DNA
inside of us that remembers that well I
think when people get into situations
where they need entertainment and back
then right like would you rather go to a
play or see a dude to have a sword fight
against a tiger tiger yeah all day
depends on what plays are boring couple
plays would be good what what playing
Neverland maybe if you I mean if there's
a line and on the left you get to see a
guy fight a lion with a sword and on the
right you see a bunch of people pretend
to be cat [ __ ] I'm gonna go see that
guy get eaten you know watch it's
terrifying to watch but the the shock
and the the just the entertainment value
before death yeah we got tickets to be
the worst good stories have been written
yet so what the hell do you think they
were doing they had plays I mean they
had great stories I'm sure they had
great stories but it's not as good like
and also the value of human life was so
much lower than right people were
constantly going to war and then with
the war that they fought they fought
with bows and arrows and Spears and
swords so there's just bloodiness
horrible bloody this probably four or
five dead people on the street at the
moment so maybe you're like I'm not
gonna go see somebody else die in there
we need to see this play and part of the
problem was like the way they got rid of
her
- right like the streets would be
contaminated with [ __ ] you should have
buried it like we did around my
neighborhood imagine the the the
blowback if someone in some country did
put together a Coliseum and then people
started travelling there and it became
like the new hot spot well if I lived in
Africa I would do that because it's you
know I know that some places are so
starved they have so many animals I
think they have a lot of people who
believe in reincarnation well just do it
a million dollars to have a sword fight
if you had a purse of a million dollars
for someone have a sword fight and they
give him a shield and armor and a sword
and a helmet they're gonna have a sword
fight with a tiger people would sign up
for that I mean I feel like you would
know almost better than anybody cuz you
guys spend you spend more time around
you know the closest kind of thing maybe
we have to some type of gladiators
modern day what do you think would any
of those men do it yeah yeah people
would do it what is this Jamie 2011 man
fights lion to boost Egypt tourism what
come on yeah come on this is real
sitting in there with a little plastic
lawn chair he's got a shield it's got a
spear the shield is a shadiest fault
what and the [ __ ] dude hell yeah a lot
of room either not a giant lion but is
this this actually happened a hundred
percent live like recorded videos on CBS
News Jesus Christ this guy get jacked or
what and this isn't it's not showing it
it must not have been a long fight and
it was probably subdued the attack
it's obviously happening if this guy
recorded then it's probably I'm Jay
escaped he had to do like a two minutes
or something with it I bet yeah the line
seems fine he's gonna climb on top he's
a winner yeah he's gonna do like a
[ __ ] cage drop drop down on that line
imagine that the balls you'd have to
leap down with a spear and drive it
through the lion's brain
from the top rope play spray all over
the place you could do it someone would
do it if that dummy got in there with
that lion you could definitely get if
you gave someone a million dollars yeah
he gave them a shield and a sword and an
armor give him some armor not all armor
yeah peace lion would leap on you so
fast your soar to be knocked out of your
hand it would just crush your [ __ ]
head with its teeth but one man would do
it yeah one man would win maybe the the
mountain from Game of Thrones
the Giant dude yeah give that guy like a
battle axe like a [ __ ] 85 pound axe
who we do it in UFC who would who do you
think could win and it's not saying that
the greatest of the best but who could
do that you'd have to be the biggest
guys it has to be like the heavyweight
champ would have to be like Stevie
Miocic or Francis and Ghana or someone
giant it would have to be a big powerful
person because you'd have to be able to
swing that [ __ ] sword fast and you
have to be able to take a hit I'm a 500
pound cat you're probably gonna get
[ __ ] up either way though you need
what you met yet if you able to take one
good hit like you're gonna take one good
hit um I just feel like you're just
gonna get [ __ ] up I just don't think
you have a chance there's a lot of
debates about this when I was reading it
earlier of course people there's a lot
of people just as stupid as me and Theo
the line wouldn't have a good technique
for you it doesn't matter if it has good
technique the physical power of a lion
it's just so overwhelming I just don't
think people understand how much force
it can generate how quickly can move how
quickly you get you it'd be box it would
just [ __ ] spray on you it would be on
you so fast dude there's a video
hilarious video of a bunch of dudes
running away from me in comparison a
leopard is what hundred fifty pounds or
something like that and these [ __ ]
people are running left and right and
this thing's coming after them and you
realize like oh my god
like look at this this guy running
now watch the leper take the corner look
just look at he slides the leopard is
going so fast it's running on the walls
on the top like the middle of the wall
above his [ __ ] head watch how as he
starts running forward and the leopard
comes into the picture the leopard is
literally running on a vertical wall
look watch this watch when it comes
around the corner look at this
it's running on the wall it's got so
much power that it's running on the side
of the wall like you can't even imagine
the kind of physical speed and strength
that that thing has in its body it's
bouncing from the side of the wall to
the other side of the wall and just
trying to get some traction so he could
get a hold of your [ __ ] ass damn no way
to get ahold of your [ __ ] ass you don't
have a chance that thing mmm that's a
fraction of the size of a lion just a
fraction [ __ ] man
oh Jesus Christ listen to school oh no
this is a video game isn't it look at it
climb over the top of that fence like it
ain't [ __ ] this one of those video games
on the dark web I think hmm
middle school leopard dude you find that
thing you just gotta shoot it
you just gotta shoot it there's not much
you could do oh it's [ __ ] this dude
up oh Jesus Oh
oh my god the board they just bit him
and then ran off he got lucky
yeah he got lucky that there's all those
other people in the commotion and 4
million people have watched I so would
it so as people we're ready to see that
yeah 4 million people have safely washed
out and they're not crying at a center
right now or anything like that
yeah but watching that doesn't seem real
you know we watched that if you were
there in real life mm-hmm like if you're
in that hockey rink mm-hmm sit in those
excellent gold star seats we're in
Mexico I think you're in China somewhere
yeah but China this is how it got the
guy Wow
coming around here I try to climb the
fence
gotcha Wow look at your bag him down oh
my god
what do you do it just wants to get out
it doesn't know what it wants right it
doesn't know what the [ __ ] it wants do
you jump in the water do you think they
swim swim oh well that's not good you
think he's bleeding or not
oh yeah he's getting his legs his arms
his legs everything's getting torn up
all that shit's on the ground that's
blood that's his blood I don't want that
on there you definitely don't like that
I just think we really need to
understand when you thought you're
talking about a large predatory animal
really didn't need to understand what
[ __ ] we are the toughest man that's
ever lived is a weak-ass [ __ ] compared
to a leopard just a fact
oh Jesus Lee this one [ __ ] man who's
doing all this oh I've seen this one
this is in India right yeah it happens
in these areas and these cats they get
into these villages and just start
[ __ ] people up that's so crazy
imagine that and it's a small animal and
compared to a lion in comparison
anything else to you before we wrap this
[ __ ] up bring it home I think I've seen
enough today well I hope you realize
that uh if you're ever in a
confrontation one of those animals
that's gonna be difficult yeah do you
realize that have that in your mind now
yeah I think it's not a game as much as
I thought it was you know there's more
of a game well I think this I think it
would be neat to go out and hunt some
type of an animal with a knife to start
to get my guard up hunt an animal with a
knife do you think you could even hunt a
raccoon with a knife yeah do you think
you could 150 percent do you think the
raccoon might [ __ ] you up though [ __ ] no
man how quick do you think a raccoon
moves like if you don't get that first
stab into that like that you do that
double up how long do you think it takes
before that thing is latched to hold at
your face claw in your eyeballs out of
your [ __ ] head and you're feeling
your eyeballs getting shot out of your
skull because it tears through your
tissue paper thin
lids like they're nothing and it's just
biting luck man
chewing your eyes out no I think if it
got on you well the the tough part is if
it gets on you you can't stab it because
you'll stab yourself this is Kevin Rose
this is Kevin Rose got a raccoon chucked
it down the stairs
titty yeah he [ __ ] that rock coming up
the raccoon was [ __ ] his dog up
that's a guy who loves his dog yeah he
said he didn't even realize he was doing
it he was just doing it before even it
was happening but look how he did it he
hooked it like a like a pillow wolf
[ __ ] BAM damn mm-hmm yeah they went
after it it's a gangster I go out that's
pretty gangster yeah what's probably
like you said it's just that's a that's
natural instinct that's the basic entry
instinct of a man you know well what I
was saying was what those guys were
talking about when they encountered that
grizzly bear they just you reach this
survival mode you have your regular
operating system and then there's
survival default mode when some real
[ __ ] goes down [ __ ] grizzly bears
right next to you well I would hate that
and well I think that you know going
back to like we were saying earlier like
that's the moment you'd find out who you
are and I would hate to find out at that
moment that I'm not a fighter you know
well that that all could be built up
right you can build that up through
martial arts right that you like there's
people that are just naturally inclined
to never quit and then there's people
that have to learn it but you can learn
it yeah yeah I want to start learning
some of it to have just a little bit
more that um just to fill in whatever
that space inside of me is sometimes
that feels a little bit inferior I don't
need to feel invincible invincible no
but I do I wouldn't mind getting a
little caulk in some of those areas
where it's like okay if somebody grabs
me like I I know that I'll be able to
grab them back right yeah man take your
Jitsu it's easy you already know Eddie
yeah yeah why not man come on take some
beginner classes start slow it's fun to
men you really enjoy it as long as and
you're a healthy guy like mentally like
as far as your ego as long as you don't
try to not tap yeah no I don't need to
win I've just be I think I'd be happy to
have the camaraderie yeah and I would be
I think that's happening is probably
some humility
very good for you it is definitely it's
just hard to do okay especially you know
when you're in the beginning you'll try
to resist you try to resist an armbar
that maybe you should tap and you can
get hurt mmm that's how you can get hurt
you get hurt from not tapping especially
other beginners they don't know how har
like a black belt you're more safe
rolling with a black belt than with
anybody is that they're gonna be able to
tap you if they want to and when they do
they're not gonna hurt you right whereas
like someone you might get in there with
some Herculean white belt who's just
learning the techniques he grabs hold of
your arms like [ __ ] Yanks on it you
don't even have a chance to tap yeah and
you're hurt and you're hurt right yeah
that's a good point I think yeah maybe
I'll see if that he can help me out to
get me he can yeah he can dude last
night was weird at the Comedy Store
wasn't it dude it was so weird they
fourth of July is a strange night to
perform people like why are we here and
you're like why are you here it was a
weird crowd it was a great crowd you're
good but they they they also felt odd
that they were at a show yeah I didn't
realize it until you said that you're
like you're like yeah these people are
thinking it's fourth of July with the
[ __ ] hundred a comedy show it's not
wrong it's not right but it's just like
does my calendar even work the weirdest
crowd you'll ever experience is
Christmas yeah you ever do Christmas
shows at the store yeah I did one
Christmas show the store like ten years
ago I'm like well I'm taking this night
out for the rest of my life [ __ ] crowds
weird man
they were weird it was more than 10
years ago cuz it had to be like 2006 you
had fun no you haven't it wasn't weird
Oh last night yeah last night was fun
last time fun yeah got a good time but
it's just it's a different feeling but I
think people are feeling differently
about comedy now because so many people
are really politically correct outside
of comedy and almost forced into it like
you're hearing so many things about
people getting fired from their jobs
because of sexual harassment or from a
sexually harassing joke like someone
would say jokes in the office that were
inappropriate and so they got fired and
this is happening left and right hear
about the guy from Netflix that got
fired for doing yeah he's having a car
conversation about offensive words that
you shouldn't be using in comedy and
because of this conversation during this
conversation about this subject he used
the word [ __ ] right because he was in
this conversation did it one other time
apparently because of that not calling
anybody that saying it out loud yeah I
was fired from Netflix that is crazy
unless if he was saying it like he like
is having a good time right like he was
like you know right now like how was he
saying it was that's the thing right but
the thing is it's very strange that that
word is only forbidden by the people
that can't it can't be used on right you
can't use the n-word on you work but if
you can use it on someone and they
happen to be a person of color then that
person you're not allowed to do that
right it's very interesting man well I
remember when I would go when I would
ride my bike to school a lot of my black
friends would get on my bike you know
and they'd get on and I would ride I
mean it was fun you know
and they used to call me the [ __ ] bus
whenever I rolled up
I never doll call me that and I honestly
felt and they were my friends it was fun
right so but you couldn't say it you
know and I could I couldn't say it and
also look I find you know when somebody
says anything if it's something to do
with a race a gender anything and they
have malice or ill intent and these days
I think if you do that somebody's gonna
correct you really [ __ ] quick and so
I agree and in a bit but in a business
setting man and that type of setting
it's just yeah you you make people so
aware that they can't I don't know
that's it is it is crazy but it's also
he was talking about forbidden words and
calm right it's his business right like
you're saying he can't make a sound with
his mouth yeah this is what you're
saying you're not he's not calling
someone that name right he's using that
word and people filed complaints about
him using that word so the people that
he worked with ratted him out but he
wasn't just allowed to say the word
right like but the correct then then it
gets real crazy whereas if you're a
black guy you could say it all day and
it's funny yeah
you'd say it in front of white people
and they can laugh right but they can't
say it but they can't say they can't say
it yeah but I view Chris Rock you can go
up at the ORR tonight and just have like
15 different use of that word in a
half-hour set yeah and no and everyone's
like that was great yeah that was a
great show right but then yeah but then
it'll be the same people that say we
should never say or hear this word it's
interesting some people learn it from
different places some people learn it
from black people some people learn it
from white people it has a different
feel a different meaning to it well and
I was even talking with mr. Peterson the
other day who and I was saying you know
the toughest thing I find especially
come from the area I came from were you
know there was a lot of racism was
probably kind of went it was popular
when I was young but it was a part of
the it was part of the tip of the cloth
and there in the area you know it's poor
black and poor white and bright you know
poor people like to [ __ ] fight you
know it's caused everything it's like
yeah it's like hey let's be on the same
team for a minute you know and we can
change the love that bit you have about
white privilege oh thanks man hilarious
bit thing but did you did you find it
fun talking to someone like Peterson
does it was it challenging it was
challenging I felt nervous you know I
felt nervous because you know I'm not as
smart as him you know most people aren't
right but I also felt you know I know
that you know he really admired you he
mentioned in the beginning so that made
me feel a little bit more comfortable
because we had something in common and
then and then he's a nice guy
and I thought he is a I tried as much as
I could to I wasn't trying to pick him a
part of the thing I just wanted to see
what he cared about and he just
genuinely I swear to God I genuinely
maybe more than anyone I've ever met he
genuinely I think cares about trying to
help young men feel better yeah for in
that you know we didn't get into
anything political or anything like that
it was mostly about you know like take a
small step take a small step and you can
change your life you know if you have a
if you have accurate goals well he's a
real clinical psychology yes and he
understands the traps that the mind
leaves for itself
yeah and we all fall into those traps
yeah
we all do yeah and I've fallen into a
lot of them and and you know it so it
was nice I mean I you know I was you I
I'm I think of him as like I thought a
Guevara
like you know like Che Guevara but like
Canadian K like I wanted to tell him
that so bad enough for God but you know
che guevara is supposed to be a
murderous monster right and he's not
like that he's not like a socialist like
that but um but he you know what he's
like that he's kind of like the dad that
a lot of us didn't hear and we need to
hear again and it's like we need those
reminders of some of those things and
and I think he genuinely to me he
genuinely wants humanity to be well
that's what I felt for me it does but
the thing is when you want men to feel
better women will think you want them to
feel bad and this is the problem that we
have with this whole right versus left
male versus female black versus Y
anytime there's two groups and they're
supposedly pitted against each other
anything positive for one side becomes
negative for the other side but I think
it's the opposite I think that if men
feel better
they'll be nicer to women and I think
that if they get their [ __ ] together
it's better for everybody and I think
that if someone's looking for men's like
look at men's values or men's lives
they're not disregarding women but we
look at it that way like know you should
be paying attention to women you're
obviously a misogynist you're focusing
on men's right it's like there's a it's
an insult to call someone an MRA which
is a men's rights activist it's kind of
hilarious you know like what is with but
like if someone was a women's rights
activist would you ever say there would
be an insult to call someone a woman's
right activist or an advocate that's
crazy now but it's openly dismissed from
the feminine side making fun of the
masculine side like men's rights
activists are openly dismissed yeah
really it's very strange yeah I like to
think you know I I get to meet a lot of
women's rights activists and look the
strongest the hardest-working man I've
ever known was my mother you know and
I'll say that to the end of the earth I
mean my mother delivered newspapers
since I was born still does you know and
and she sacrificed a lot of raising
her children she wasn't there for us
emotionally because she had to work all
the time
right you know she didn't even have she
did have the opportunity to be but you
want to talk about a feminist like I
never known one more in my life I don't
think you know she had to play a man and
a woman you know in a lot of in a lot of
instances and I that's great that you
appreciate her oh I love it to the end
but they mean so much to you yeah and we
start even like I started doing this
thing we're like we try and like treat a
single mom out to like a weekend when
I'm out on a weekend of shows you know
pay for the sitter pay for the dinner
you know and and not to object a single
dad's you know but you know for me like
I uh you know like I was even talking
with mr. Peterson about this like I
never got to make like the reason I
think I got in economy I never got to
make my mom laugh you know like she was
always suzhou is tired she was always
working hard and tired and we just
didn't have that connection mm-hmm you
know and so I think that's one of the
reasons I got in the county the only
person I've ever really probably wanted
to make laughs as my mother don't know
and then Here I am like just doing all
this other chicanery on the outside did
your mom think that you were funny when
you were when you first started I don't
know no I don't think he I don't think
she thought of anything like that my mom
literally said to me I just don't think
you're very funny Oh mom dude I saw that
young the video the young video usually
comedy with the longest hair on the
sides and stuff yeah I was a little
cutie dude that was the best but it was
a really cool video I was probably like
24 23 Wow
maybe 23 1 2 3 yeah somewhere in that
range man crazy but I think I'd like to
you know a lot of some of these do you
know aggressive sometimes angry
feminists they're not mothers either
I mean that's odd to me like you know
people get you know they get into
something because they feel there's an
imbalance yeah and if it's true feminism
or they get into being a men's rights
activist I feel bad for those guys
because I think a lot of those guys have
just been [ __ ] over by bad
relationships or shitty divorces or you
know shitty laws in terms of like child
custody and then they you know this is
their the response
it's what we would really like is for
everyone to be treated as an individual
yeah and and and no groups no male
versus female no [ __ ] right versus
left just all human beings individuals
and I think that's like the ultimate
goal for a society for a healthy society
it's not to not eliminate judging people
but judge people based on their actions
and their words and their deeds hmm not
their sex or their you know but then
you're always gonna have people that
want to [ __ ] the opposite sex and you're
always gonna have people that want to
[ __ ] the same sex too and make them
uncomfortable like I've been hit on by
dudes before it and been made to feel
very uncomfortable yeah I'm sure you
have to the only difference is I know
how to fight and when a dude was hitting
on me I was like listen cut the [ __ ]
like this wasn't a scene where you know
I was worried I was gonna get raped it
was I was worried I was gonna go to jail
for [ __ ] somebody up right I don't
want to have to hurt you man but don't
touch my dick again right I've been in
situations before but it was never a
situation where I was like a woman where
I was worried I was gonna get held down
and someone's gonna do something too
right but you can understand them when
those situations like I can easily see
how women feel that way like way worse
yeah way worse yeah I get that too it's
like I'll get like dick pics and stuff
from men into my instagrams and stuff
bro and it's [ __ ] like Oh some dudes
are aggressive with it but that's nice
six-zero did he fix zero well you're
gonna get them right now they come
people feel bad for Theo
there's something bold about a girl
should send you a picture of her tits
this guy sends a picture of his dick a
sumptuous [ __ ] a girl's sending you
something you're excited to see yes like
if a girl sends you pictures of her tits
and she's holding I'm she was like I
heard you wanted these you're like whoa
those real this is crazy
yeah I need a Gatorade yeah somebody
gets those like oh but sexually harassed
by this woman shot mouths [ __ ] up you're
fine [ __ ] walk it off
dude I yeah it's so it's so true that
but I dunno I start to notice how people
feel I start to notice how yeah when
that happens like I'll see how you feel
I see now see how women feel if they get
that you get there's a door that you
could look through where you could see a
mile away maybe where this could go
right but to be the person that feels
that like a dude once the stick is
digging you and shoot loads into your
body that's crazy it's wait video game
that's you know that's the difference
between men and women yeah and this is
also why there's more anger because
women have experienced so many guys
trying to do that to them that they
develop this bad taste for men and I
understand that and we need to be better
man you know and I believe that in an
honesty that's one of the reasons why
you know I listen to your show it's one
of the reasons why you know I'm excited
you know I was intrigued to listen to
mr. Peterson and reading his book and
you know I do want to be a better man
and it's harder you want to be a better
human being whoever you are
yeah we all want to do better and if you
don't want to do better you're probably
gonna have a [ __ ] up life because then
you're not trying you're not perfect
it's no way you're perfect no one who's
ever lived has been perfect I mean every
one day yeah and every day you have to
pay attention every day you got to pay
attention every day to your behavior to
the way you think and you have to
constantly being us be assessing it and
moving it in the right direction and
when you are moving it in a positive
generous loving direction it feels
better you feel better yeah you feel
like a better person yeah you really
yeah you really do
you know I'm glad that um yeah I'm just
glad to be like alive and be able to
like try and like learn about [ __ ] it is
exciting
you know it is exciting and you know I
think one of the things that [ __ ]
people up more than anything this is
what I've experienced this with so many
friends like dude you're thinking about
your past like it's you and it's not mmm
you've you can't beat yourself up for
something you did 20 years ago or the
way you were you know doing coke and
[ __ ] your life up five years ago
that's not you anymore yeah like you did
do those things yeah but that doesn't
mean you are who you want that you're
you're not that person anymore yeah like
as long as you decide but if you get
caught in that
trap you'll be that person again yeah a
person again I mean there's we all know
that one dude that can't stop can't stop
he takes a few months off I'm sober
enough now everything's doing good and
then whoo off to the races again shows
up coked up drunk comes the commies door
won't shut the [ __ ] up breathing [ __ ]
breath and everybody's face like Jesus
sweat dripping off his earlobes seven
fingers in his ass we all know that dude
there's so many of those dudes yeah they
just can't they never break free they
break for you for a little while and
never go wow I don't want to be that
person anymore they just go well I'm not
that person this week and then you know
they just get addicted to being sober
for a little while and then next thing
you know there's Dark Arts dark Horus
why do you call it dark just because
it's anything that thing takes you out
of like your path towards like some sort
of enlightenment a little bit mmm
that's what I think you know Dark Arts
they got in Harry Potter like Voldemort
and everybody you doing dirty spells
like his bro
turning candy and the worms and
everything right yeah anything that
takes you off of the path of
enlightenment yeah is the dark arts
that's most things don't write most
times you're jerking off
oh yeah arts yeah I've come with myself
so many times bro right and when you do
do you ever feel good about it do you
ever feel like yeah that's what
sometimes season like occasionally gonna
four days bro not even joking
sometimes during the holidays I'm just
so filled with joy that the shame
doesn't get me do you know that it
actually does alleviate anxiety and
people recommend doing it before you
have a performance you have to perform
in front of people yeah it's not a bad
idea
whack one off and your hotel room before
you go to a show you'd be like less
anxious I could see that maybe maybe for
like a special or something you know
diovan that was just three hours
was it really Wow or more than three
hours how long was it 320g is the
longest conversation I've ever been in
this [ __ ] room dude something happens
in this place I don't know even know how
it works
Theo Vaughn calm Theo von on Twitter or
Theo von on Instagram when you're on the
road next I'm actually gonna be in
Oxnard tonight through
yeah life that's a great club is it I've
never been oh you're gonna love it
it's great it's a sweet setup it's
[ __ ] awesome crowd they're pumped
something's out there yeah you know it's
like a mini Bakersfield oh wow closer I
like that's the closer though I'm
excited dude I'm gonna try that
Brazilian Jujitsu and I might [ __ ] your
cutter knife fight a raccoon let's see
won't you better leave the raccoons
alone okay get into that jujitsu son
yeah oh all right we'll be back next
week you freaks bye thanks
[Music]